Guys, who's fired up to do some podcasts? And what kind of energy do you feel when you're going to just podcast this shit out of something? I'm going to do it. I raced downstairs. I didn't even take a shower. I put my headphones on. I saw you guys. I got really excited.
大家，谁想做播客？当你要把这破事大谈特谈时，你有什么样的感觉？我来做。我一路冲下楼。我甚至没有洗澡。我戴上耳机。我看到你们了。我非常兴奋。
We're going to chat today. And then I'm going to take a shower. You don't have anything prepared for this cold open? You didn't eat anything? No. I usually have a hot coffee holding in your hand yeah it's the that's his first little wrist when he's typing do you do that much typing where you need a little pat for your wrists I just had the I had carpal tunnel in my hand uh-huh and then what happened decided to use the other hand all right good for you. Welcome to Smart List. Smart. Last.
我们今天要聊聊天。然后我要去洗澡。你对这个冷开场什么都没准备吗？你什么都没吃吗？没有。我通常手里拿着一杯热咖啡，对，那是他打字时的第一个小护腕，你用得着打那么多字，需要一个小护腕吗？我刚刚得过腕管综合征，然后呢，决定用另一只手，好吧，你真行。欢迎来到《聪明笨蛋》。聪明。笨蛋。
Smart. Last. Smart. Last. So we already know that our mystery guest is a female and she's no stranger to a giggle. She keeps it light. She likes to giggle.
聪明。笨蛋。聪明。笨蛋。所以我们已经知道，我们的神秘嘉宾是一位女性，而且她对咯咯笑并不陌生。她保持轻松。她喜欢咯咯笑。
Yeah. She likes to giggle. And that's what we know so far. So... Are you doing early guessing game? Yeah. Let's start. You know what?
对。她喜欢咯咯笑。这就是我们目前所了解的。所以……你在做早期的猜谜游戏吗？对。我们开始吧。你知道吗？
Give me the first letter of the first name. No. Okay. First letter of the last name. No. Okay, first letter of the last name. No. Okay. Jesus. No, all right.
告诉我名字的首字母。不。好吧。姓氏的首字母。不。好吧，姓氏的首字母。不。好吧。天哪。不，好吧。
I just, I was like, you know what? You know what, no. And I should go, yes, I did, I should play on it. No, no. All right, well then let's get into our opening pattern. Or some pattern. Sean, do you have anything prepared? I didn't have anything prepared.
我只是，我当时想，你知道吗？你知道吗，不。我应该去，是的，我做了，我应该顺着它说。不，不。好吧，那我们进入我们的开场模式吧。或者某种模式。肖恩，你有什么准备吗？我什么都没准备。
Here we go, hit access to the file. But I'm drinking tea. I was going to ask you, do you leave your tea bags in or do you take them out? Today mine are in. That's something sexual about that. I know. There is something. The last time you were tea bagged in or out.
我们开始吧，点击访问文件。但我正在喝茶。我正想问你，你是把茶包留在里面还是拿出来？今天我的在里面。这听我知道。里面有点什么。你上次茶包是留在里面还是拿出来。
Oh, it was a teabag in. Now Sean, are you a little bit under the web? He is. And I was just telling Jason, I hope I didn't get you guys sick on Tuesday. And I reminded him. I don I hope I didn't get you guys sick on Tuesday. And I don't think I did. I reminded him that it was all, there was no open mouth kissing at all.
哦，茶包在里面。现在肖恩，你有点身体不适吗？他是。我刚才还在告诉杰森，我希望我周二没有传染给你们。我提醒过他。我不，我希望我周二没有传染给你们。我觉得我没有。我提醒过他，这都是，完全没有张嘴接吻。
It was all closed. I kept asking you actually to stop kissing and don't look at me. Because you usually say eyes on me, open eyes, eyes on me. Eyes please, eyes please. Hey, that's a good question. When you guys kiss your significant other, do you keep your eyes open or do you close them?
全是闭着嘴的。其实我一直在请求你停止接吻，别看着我。因为你通常会说，看着我，睁开眼睛，看着我。请看着我，请看着我。嘿，这是一个好问题。当你们亲吻另一半时，你们是睁着眼睛还是闭着眼睛？
Whole time. Whole time open? The whole time open. It's so great. Right open, looking at, reacting for reaction. I like to stare right into the makeup artist's eyes when they're powdering me. It really freaks them out.
全程。全程睁着？全程睁着。太棒了。大睁着，看着，为了反应而做出反应。我喜欢当化妆师给我扑粉时，直直地盯着他们的眼睛。这真的会把他们吓坏。
Yeah, no blinking, just hard eye contact when they're powdering me. No. Tracy, getting powdered is something that's common and not freaky for people in front of the camera. But Jason, you famously don't wear a lot of makeup when you do your gigs. Well, the stuff I've been doing lately,
对，不眨眼，在我扑粉时进行强烈的眼神接触。不。翠西，扑粉对镜头前的人来说是一件很常见、并不诡异的事情。但是杰森，你出了名地在演出时不怎么化浓妆。好吧，我最近做的事，
you're not meant to look healthy or happy. You've got that cover. And that role you've been playing for 20 years. Yeah, I was going to, I'm going into a new thing. Or it's, I just don't think I'm going to be much in the makeup trailer at all. Yeah, you got a real look going these days. I know, right?
你不需要看起来健康或快乐。你有那个封面。还有你演了20年的那个角色。对，我要，我要尝试新东西。或者说，我只是觉得我以后根本不会怎么去化妆间了。对，你最近真的很有型。我懂，对吧？
This stupid hair. I think I do need to get it thinned out. It's gross. No, no, no, no, no. Right a bummer. Hair is too thick. It's too thick. I mean, No, Shani, Shani, I noticed you sneezing. No, no, I caught that was a cough Oh, there was a cough your coffee. I'm saying if you guys feel anything by Saturday or Sunday. You're in the clear
这蠢头发。我想我确实需要把它打薄一点。太恶心了。不，不，不，不，不。真倒霉。头发太厚了。太厚了。我是说，不，肖尼，肖尼，我注意到你在打喷嚏。不，不，我抓住那是个咳嗽，哦，那是咳嗽，你的咳嗽。我是说如果你们在周六或周日有任何感觉。你们就安全了
Okay, I got a weight. This is there's a five-day incubation period in your virus. Yeah, great I think we're fine. All right. What about Scotty? Does he have it? He had it before, but I didn't get sick from him. Well, we know why. Yeah. Why? He's been on the watch for me. Listener, Sean's really on the skids with Scotty. There's a countdown for the...
好吧，我得等。这，你们的病毒有五天的潜伏期。对，太好了，我觉得我们没事。好吧。斯科蒂呢？他得过吗？他以前得过，但我没有被他传染。好吧，我们知道为什么。对。为什么？他一直在盯着我。听众们，肖恩跟斯科蒂的关系真的陷入低谷了。有个倒计时……
No. No. That's gonna be available any minute. No. You guys are about the best couple I've ever met. I know. We all have great partners. We do.
不。不。随时都可以买到。不。你们绝对是我见过最好的一对。我知道。我们都有很好的伴侣。我们确实有。
And I was just describing Scotty the other day to, somebody's asking me, and I said, he's just the nicest, sweetest dude. He's so considerate. He is, and he looks like a box. He's in the shape of a box. Okay. Well, I didn't get into that, but.
前几天我还在向某人描述斯科蒂，有人问我，我说，他简直是最好、最甜的人。他太体贴了。他是，而且他看起来像个箱子。他长得像个箱子形状。好吧。嗯，我没扯到那儿，不过。
A boxy bear. But he is such a sweet sort of legitimately like considerate person. Yeah, he's the nicest person I've ever met. And not from Canada. I know. I know. You'd think he would be. Shockingly, I know.
一只方方的小熊。但他真的是那种非常甜美、名副其实的体贴的人。对，他是我见过最好的人。而且不是加拿大人。我知道。我知道。你本来会以为他是的。出人意料的是，我知道。
All those Canadians are super nice. We'll introduce Sean and I to a couple of Canadians the other day who were just like right out of the middle of the page for like Yeah, well well intention tell you Canadians are friendly, but like I don't know well then you meet them. It's like yeah Yeah, they're all like the nicest people in the world, and it's not learned. It's not contrived. It's it's just so genuine Well, you know Paula's Canadian, but Jenny's American but I wasn't getting his nice of I bought for her. Yeah Oh, genuine. Well, you know, Paul is Canadian, but Jenny's American. But his little kid is Canadian. I wasn't getting his nice vibe off of her.
所有加拿大人都超级好。前几天肖恩和我遇到了一对加拿大人，他们简直就像从书页里走出来的一样，真的，言之凿凿，我告诉你加拿大人很友好，但是，我不知道，等你见到他们。就像是，是的，他们就像是世界上最好的人，而且不是学来的。不是装出来的，就是那么真诚。好吧，你知道保拉是加拿大人，但珍妮是美国人，不过我从她身上没有感受到那么好的气场。是的，哦，真诚。好吧，你知道保拉是加拿大人，但珍妮是美国人。但他的小孩是加拿大人。我从她身上没有感受到那种好气场。
Yeah. Interesting. That's a good point. You're getting a selfish kind of self-adorbs. Something domestic, yeah. I tell you, I tell you he's got a pretty good vibe. Oh, nice. This is a segue.
是的。有趣。说得好。你给人一种自私、自我陶醉的感觉。有点家庭主妇的感觉，对吧。我跟你说，我跟你说他的气场相当不错。哦，不错。这是一个过渡。
Here comes Giggles. Tell you he's got a pretty good vibe. Is our guest today. Do you like him? Do you like people who can do different things? She is a juggler from Northern Saskatchewan. They can go on to Broadway, Sean, you like Broadway? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. They can go on to Broadway, they can sing songs,
咯咯笑来了。跟你说他气场相当不错。是我们今天的嘉宾。你喜欢她吗？你喜欢能做不同事情的人吗？她是来自萨斯喀彻温省北部的杂耍艺人。他们可以去百老汇，肖恩，你喜欢百老汇吗？哦，对，对，对。他们可以去百老汇，他们可以唱歌，
they can sell records. They could sell 25 million albums worldwide. 40 million singles. Have a multi Emmy award winning daytime talk show. Can be really plugged into the heart of America because this person was found and discovered in the heart of America. She's one of the most successful... Kelly Clarkson. Kelly Clarkson.
他们可以卖唱片。他们可以全球售出2500万张专辑。4000万张单曲。拥有一个多次获得艾美奖的日间脱口秀节目。能够真正深入美国的心脏，因为这个人是在美国的心脏地带被发现和发掘的。她是最成功的……凯莉·克拉克森。凯莉·克拉克森。
Kelly Clarkson. Kelly Clarkson. Yeah, I got it. Hi Kelly. I was like, hello. Willie guessed my guess the other day. Now I got you back. I know you did. You did.
凯莉·克拉克森。凯莉·克拉克森。对，我猜对了。嗨，凯莉。我当时想，你好。威利前几天猜中了我的嘉宾。现在我扳回一城。我知道你做到了。你真的做到了。
Hi Kelly Clarkson. Hi Kelly Clarkson. Kelly, I haven't seen you since Saturday Night Live maybe? Oh my gosh. Okay, so I was going to bring it up. I don't even know if you, I don't know if you remember that I was on there with you, but. Of course. I was terrified of you.
嗨，凯莉·克拉克森。嗨，凯莉·克拉克森。凯莉，我可能从《周六夜现场》之后就没见过你了？哦，天哪。好吧，所以我要提出来。我甚至不知道你，我不知道你是否还记得我和你一起上过节目，但是。当然。我当时吓坏了。
Oh, welcome to the show. No, you were nice. No, you were so nice. I was like, I literally, I remember telling my band, I was like, I had like a whole prep talk. I was like, don't fucking talk. You're gonna say something stupid. I was like, I was like, just smile and just stand there.
哦，欢迎来到节目。不，你人很好。不，你人太好了。我当时想，我真的，我记得我告诉我的乐队，我当时想，我给自己做了一整套心理建设。我当时想，别他妈说话。你会说蠢话的。我当时想，我当时想，就微笑，站在那儿。
And I was like, very nervous. That whole week I was petrified. Was that your first? Oh, you did, you're amazing. And you were so nice. I just think when you are a fan of someone, so much so, and you love their personality and they, you know, you're very charismatic,
然后我就，非常紧张。那一整个星期我都吓呆了。那是你的第一次吗？哦，你做到了，你太棒了。而且你人真好。我只是觉得当你是一个人的粉丝，而且到这种程度，你喜欢他们的性格，并且他们，你知道，你非常有魅力，
you're funny and quick. And so I was like, just don't say something stupid I don't think I even spoke much you do you might you might want to withhold on the personality part you know what I mean just give it a little I'm like a dry wit asshole so he's right down there oh well there's a lot of smart let's go you're gonna love him you're gonna love them. Now I have a question about, like I remember, I'm so sorry you get these questions all the time.
你有趣又机智。所以我当时想，别说蠢话。我觉得我甚至没怎么说话。你可能，你可能想要对性格部分有所保留，你知道我的意思吗？就收敛一点。我是一个冷面笑匠，所以他正合此意。哦，好吧，这里有很多聪明人，你会喜欢他的，你会喜欢他们的。现在我有一个问题，关于，就像我记得，非常抱歉你总是被问到这些问题。
That's okay, go ahead. In 1999 or 2000, when American Idol first started, and then I remember Megan Mullally, who I did Will and Grace with, she's like, you gotta come one. And I didn't watch the show until the last. Remind Tracy what Will and Grace is. I love, no, I'm telling you, I love her and Nick.
没关系，请问。在1999年或2000年，《美国偶像》刚开播的时候，然后我记得梅根·穆拉利，我和她一起演过《威尔和格蕾丝》，她说，你一定要去。我直到最后才看这个节目。提醒一下翠西什么是《威尔和格蕾丝》。我喜欢，不，我告诉你，我喜欢她和尼克。
I'm obsessed with them. They're great. I know I love, no, I'm telling you, I love her and Nick. I'm obsessed with them. They're great. I love them too. And they, and Megan called me in her dressing room, she's like, you gotta watch this show. I'm like, what is it? It's American Idol. And of course, everybody knows the story.
我迷恋他们。他们太棒了。我知道我喜欢，不，我告诉你，我喜欢她和尼克。我迷恋他们。他们太棒了。我也喜欢他们。然后，梅根把叫到她的化妆室，她说，你必须看这个节目。我说，那是什么？是《美国偶像》。当然，大家都知道这个故事。
You know, little town girl makes it big on the show and then becomes this big pop star, blah, blah. So, but there's a sense that I've always felt around you that America is like your hours. Like, do you ever, do you constantly get bombarded by people who feel like they had a hand in your success? Oh, absolutely. But I mean, that's a very true statement.
你知道的，小镇女孩在这个节目中一举成名，然后成为大流行巨星，巴拉巴拉。所以，但我一直觉得在你周围有一种感觉，那就是美国就像是你的。就像，你是否经常被那些觉得自己在你的成功中出过力的人轰炸？哦，当然。但我的意思是，这是一个非常真实的说法。
So, for all of us, really. Yeah, I mean, I think it's true. Where would we be without the American audience? But I mean, that show is so massive and it was, and you were the first one. And then, so you're easy to root for because everybody loves you and you're so likable and I love you.
所以，对我们所有人来说，真的。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是真的。如果没有美国观众，我们会去哪里？但我的意思是，那个节目太庞大了，而且它是，而且你是第一个。然后，所以你很容易让人支持，因为每个人都喜欢你，你太讨人喜欢了，我爱你。
Debatable, but yes. And, but to see you go from the little town girl that nobody knew to every single thing that you conquered over the years, I imagine people come up to you on the street and just be like, have a sense of ownership almost in a different way. Yeah, I mean, I think it works for me
有待商榷，但是是的。而且，但是看到你从一个没人认识的小镇女孩，到这些年来你征服的每一件事，我想象人们在街上走过来对你说，几乎以一种不同的方式有一种所有权的感觉。是的，我的意思是，我觉得这对我行得通，
because like I said, I'm from a very small town. So I'm kind of used to like that. Like even doing like talent shows as a kid or like even doing musicals or you know, I've kind of used to like everyone knowing your name. It's like cheer. So you know, like I'm used to that vibe. And I think that's why people are always like,
因为就像我说的，我来自一个小镇。所以我有点习惯了那种。比如小时候参加才艺秀，或者甚至是演音乐剧，你知道的，我有点习惯了每个人都知道你的名字。就像啦啦队。所以你知道的，我习惯了那种氛围。我想这就是为什么人们总是，
oh, you're so open with like any human. I'm like, yeah, we're really all the same. And on your talk show, you're just, you're very open, you talk about everything. Yeah, I love that, Kelly. You're just like, well, it's not really that much of an effort to not be an asshole. Like what are you saying? Well, it depends on really that much of an effort to not be an asshole. Like, what are you saying?
哦，你对任何人都是如此开放。我说，是的，我们其实都一样。在你的脱口秀里，你就是，你非常开放，你什么都聊。是的，我喜欢那样，凯莉。你只是，嗯，不做一个混蛋其实不需要付出太多努力。你在说什么？好吧，这取决于，其实不做一个混蛋不需要付出太多努力。你在说什么？
Well, it depends on the person, Jason. Right. Sometimes there's a lot of effort. Yeah. But no, it's like, I think because I have that small town mentality, it's always been very easy for me and I don't mind, like I always say, I still at 41, like we'll be at Walmart in Butte, Montana
好吧，这取决于人，杰森。对。有时需要付出很多努力。是的。但不是，这就像，我想因为我有那种小镇心态，这对我来说一直都很容易，而且我不介意，就像我总是说的，我41岁了，在蒙大拿州比尤特的沃尔玛，
and go, thank you, because they're like, oh, I voted for you. And I'm like, thank you, that changed my life. I was a pretty great solid waitress, but like I really like what I'm doing now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're like, thank you, but now you're blocking my Range Rover. Okay. No, wait, Kelly, Kelly, so speaking of that,
还会说，谢谢，因为他们会说，哦，我投了你的票。我会说，谢谢，那改变了我的生活。我曾经是个相当不错的服务员，但我真的很喜欢我现在做的事。对，对，对。你会说，谢谢，但你现在挡住我的路虎了。好吧。不，等等，凯莉，凯莉，说到这个，
like now we're on that sort of the American Idol thing. And I watch you too, like everybody, when that, especially we're on that sort of the American Idol thing, and I watch you too, like everybody, especially that first season, and you were undoubtedly, I would say, and I might get some pushback, I think you're the greatest American Idol that there ever was. You were the first and you were the best by far.
就像现在我们聊到《美国偶像》那档事。我也看着你，就像每个人一样，当那个，特别是我们聊到《美国偶像》那档事时，我也看着你，就像每个人一样，特别是第一季，毫无疑问，我会说，我可能会遭到一些反对，我认为你是有史以来最伟大的美国偶像。你是第一个，也是迄今为止最好的。
I would not argue. I'll just concur. I'm just kidding. I know you would. I'm just kidding. No, but you legitimately have a great voice. Without such a discovery, would that show have really carried on
我不会反驳。我只会赞同。开玩笑的。我知道你会的。开玩笑的。不，但你确实有一副好嗓子。如果没有这样的发掘，那个节目真的能延续到它曾经的高峰吗？就像看他们能找到什么。
to the heights that it was? Like look what they can find. Yeah, who, no, I mean, believe me, it's thinking everything I got right now, the entire time I just wanna go, since you've been gone. Anyway, but, and I love, but what was that process for you?
对，谁，不，我是说，相信我，我现在脑子里在想我所能想的一切，整个过程我只想说，自从你离开后。不管怎样，但是，我喜欢，但对你来说那个过程是怎样的？
How did that come about, American Idol? Like, you know, you saw an ad in a paper. It was on Craigslist. Like, how did that go down? Oh my God, Craigslist was not around. Was it not? 2001? Was it?
《美国偶像》是怎么回事？就像，你知道的，你在报纸上看到一则广告。是在 Craigslist 上。事情是怎么发展出来的？哦，天哪，那时候还根本没有 Craigslist。没有吗？2001年？是吗？
2001, too. Wait, let me see. Can I see if I can get this right? Yes. Well, I'd rather have her answer it, but okay. No, but wait. I'm curious to know if you know it. Craigslist.
2001，2年。等等，让我看看。我看看能不能想起来？是的。好吧，我宁愿让她回答，但是好吧。不，但等等。我很好奇你想不想知道。Craigslist。
A friend challenged you or like to go on and if you went on and got on, or one or something, you'd get her a car or something like that? Something like that, yes. Well, I literally, my place had burned down the Croft Apartments off of Melrose, and literally the day we moved in,
一个朋友挑战你，或者让你去参加，如果你去参加并入选了，或者赢了什么的，你会给她买辆车什么的？差不多是这样，是的。好吧，我真的，我的住处被烧毁了，在梅尔罗斯附近的克罗夫特公寓，就在我们搬进去的那天，
we had moved from this other place, and the day we moved in, it burned down, and I ended up having to sleep in my car for like three days and I was like, okay, I can't like, I can't sustain this. So my plan was to go back home to Texas, makes more money come out because I don't know if you all know, but it's expensive to live in Los Angeles, especially when broke with three jobs.
我们刚从另一个地方搬过来，搬进去的那天，它就被烧毁了，我最后不得不睡在车里大约三天，我想，好吧，我不能，我无法维持下去了。所以我的计划是回德克萨斯老家，多赚点钱再出来，因为我不知道你们知不知道，在洛杉矶生活很贵，特别是身无分文还打着三份工的时候。
And anyway, so I on my way home, one of my friends, Jebby, Jessica, told me about this audition. On your way home from one of your jobs? Is that where it was? I know, like on my way home from California to Texas. To Texas, okay, sorry. Yeah, it was like right after, yeah. And so I got home and I didn't know what it was.
不管怎样，所以在回家的路上，我的一个朋友杰比，杰西卡，跟我说了这个试镜。是在你从其中一份工作回家的路上？是在那儿吗？我知道，就像从加利福尼亚回德克萨斯的路上。回德克萨斯，哦，抱歉。是的，就像刚结束，是的。我回到家，都不知道那是什么。
I didn't even know it was a TV show to like the third audition. Because you know, they have you go and, they had us go in like these just random rooms, like in like, for the producers, and you don't know anybody, you don't know what they're doing. Nobody had heard of Pop Idol,
我甚至不知道那是一个电视节目，直到第三轮试镜。因为你知道，他们让你去，他们让我们去那些随机的房间里，就像为制作人准备的那样，你谁也不认识，你也不知道他们在干什么。没有人听说过《流行偶像》，
which there had been one season of Pop Idol in the UK. Nobody knew that. And so I didn't know what it was. And anyway, I told, after I made it through the first rounds or whatever, I told Jebi, I was like, because honestly, I didn't think I had to win. But I was like, y'all totally buy you a car if I win. I won, so I bought her the car.
英国曾经有一季《流行偶像》。没有人知道那个。所以我不知道那是什么。不管怎样，在通过了前几轮还是什么的之后，我告诉杰比，我当时想，因为老实说，我没想到我能赢。但我当时想，如果我赢了，我绝对给你买辆车。我赢了，所以我给她买了一辆车。
That's amazing. What'd you get her? Was it a new car? It was her dream car. I think it. What'd you get her? Was it a dream car? It was like her dream car. I think it was like a Firebird or something. It was like over 20 years ago, but I believe it was like a Firebird or something. Firebird? Yeah, it was like something.
太惊人了。你给她买的什么？是一辆新车吗？那是她梦寐以求的车。我想它。你给她买的什么？是梦寐以求的车吗？就像是她梦寐以求的车。我想是一辆火鸟还是别的什么。那是20多年前的事了，但我相信是一辆火鸟什么的。火鸟？是的，就像某种。
Or not a Firebird. No. It was like a Mustang. A Mustang. I don't remember what it was. It was like a sports car, but it was like badass. But I wasn't, I'm not in a sports car. Were you surprised that you won or had you already experienced
或者不是火鸟。不是。就像一辆野马。野马。我不记得是什么了。就像一辆跑车，但非常酷。但我不是，我不坐跑车。你对自己的胜出感到意外吗？还是说你之前已经在当地取得了相当不错的成功？
a pretty good level of success locally? No, I mean, I was surprised. I mean, yeah, I'd won like, I'd won like the burles and talent show. Yeah, right, wow. But like exactly, prestigious. But you know, when you're a kid, you do those kind of things.
不，我的意思是，我很意外。我是说，是的，我赢过，我赢过伯勒尔才艺秀。是的，对，哇。但就像那样，很有声望。但你知道，当你还是个孩子的时候，你会做那种事。
And I'd had like some success in the sense of like, you know, following through on some dreams that I had like locally, but like, you know, when I was a kid, but no, I mean, I'd never won anything of like real importance or done anything. And I am like a wallflower generally. Like I don't, nobody even knows I'm in the room generally.
而且我在某种意义上也算取得了一些成功，比如，你知道的，在当地实现了一些我拥有的梦想，但是，你知道的，当我还是个孩子的时候，不，我的意思是，我从来没有赢得过什么真正重要的东西，也没有做过什么。而且我通常是个边缘人。就像，通常没人知道我在房间里。
So I did not think I was gonna win that. What was the process? So what, from the first audition, so you heard about this audition where they were gonna have, you didn't know it was a show, it was just they were looking for singers, is what you heard, is that right? Yeah.
所以我没想过我会赢。那个过程是怎样的？那么，从第一次试镜开始，你听说有这么一个试镜，他们会，你当时不知道这是一个节目，只知道他们在寻找歌手，你是这么听说的，对吗？是的。
And so they go, so you go into, you audition in Texas, and you go to the first audition, from the first audition to winning, how long was that process? Oh, like within like a year. Like it was months because it was the first season and they were still putting it all together and it was an English-based company.
所以他们去，你在德克萨斯参加试镜，你去参加第一次试镜，从第一次试镜到获胜，那个过程持续了多久？哦，大概一年之内。就像几个月，因为那是第一季，他们还在筹备中，而且那是一家英国公司。
So people were coming in and out. Are you singing the same song in every stage, every audition? They'd like you to, or they did, they asked us to. I was about to sing, I said yes to singing at someone's wedding and I was singing at last. They wanted me to sing at last. And so I think I sang at last for the first three. And then they showed this on YouTube, I think,
所以人们来来去去。你在每个阶段、每次试镜都唱同一首歌吗？他们希望你这样，或者他们确实这么做了，他们要求我们这么做。我正要唱歌，我答应在别人的婚礼上唱歌，我唱的是《At Last》。他们想让我唱《At Last》。所以我想我在前三次试镜时都唱了《At Last》。然后他们把这个发到了 YouTube 上，我想，
or released it sometime, but then they asked me to sing something faster. And I was like, seeing anything but the Mulan Rouge song. Cause everyone was singing itchy, itchy, yaya, yaya. and I was like, sing anything but the Moulin Rouge song because everyone was singing itchy, itchy, yaya, yaya. I was like, I was like, I literally in that moment was like, anything will do but that song because everyone was singing it. So I went into some Madonna song, which was random
或者在某个时候发布了，但后来他们让我唱一首快节奏的歌。我说，唱什么都行，除了《红磨坊》的那首歌。因为每个人都在唱 itchy, itchy, yaya, yaya。我当时想，唱什么都行，除了《红磨坊》的那首歌，因为每个人都在唱 itchy, itchy, yaya, yaya。我当时想，我当时在那个时刻心想，什么歌都行，就是别唱那首，因为每个人都在唱。所以我选了一首麦当娜的歌，这很随机，
because normally I don't generally sing Madonna, but... So within a year, you go driving home to so you can make more money so you don't have to live in your car to being an international superstar and that that kind of whiplash on your life forget professionally yeah whiplash on you on you sort of spiritually emotionally all that kind of stuff the The weight of it. The weight of it. And some people might say, oh, poor Kelly Clarkson.
因为我平时通常不唱麦当娜的歌，但是……所以不到一年时间，你从开车回家为了多赚钱不用睡在车里，变成了一个国际超级巨星，那种生活上的巨变，别提职业上了，是的，生活上的巨变，对你个人来说，精神上、情感上，所有这些方面，那种份量。那种份量。有些人可能会说，哦，可怜的凯莉·克拉克森。
You became rich and famous in a year. Whatever. I'm one of those people too, by the way. Of course. But it is a- Was that Jane Buffett that you were just quoting? That was Jane Buffett. That was my good friend, Jane Buffett.
你一年之内就变得富有和出名了。随便吧。顺便说一句，我也是那种人。当然。但这是一个——刚才引用的是简·巴菲特的话吗？那是简·巴菲特。那是我的好朋友简·巴菲特。
No, she never said that, Jane. That's just a great Jane accent. I know, she's the best. Was, what was that like, Kelly, for you? Like sort of, not the day after you win, but in the sort of the time after as your life just has a dramatic shift. What was that like for you as a person,
不，她从没说过那样的话，简。那只是一个很棒的简式口音。我知道，她是最棒的。凯莉，那对你来说是什么样的？比如，不是你夺冠后的第二天，而是在之后的日子里，随着你的生活发生了戏剧性的转变。作为一个人，一个在这个星球上行走的人，那对你来说是什么样的？
as a human being walking this planet? You know, really cool moments and then like a lot of not great ones. So I think I'm a very trusting person. Well, I think the scary part comes when it's more the human factor. It's not the working. I've always had like three or four jobs at a time. I've always enjoyed being busy.
你知道，有一些非常酷的时刻，然后有许多不太好的时刻。所以我觉得我是一个非常容易信任别人的人。嗯，我觉得可怕的部分往往在于人际因素。而不是工作本身。我以前总是同时打三四份工。我一直很喜欢忙碌。
I like being productive. So you know, that wasn't a, it wasn't so much the scheduling was intense, but it wasn't too much. It's the human factor, it's the lying, and it's the people, it's like, what are we doing here? It's the lying, like literally, and that really got me down, the human factor got me down.
我喜欢有产出。所以你知道，那不是，时间安排虽然很紧张，但并不是太多。是人际因素，是谎言，是人，就像，我们在这里干什么？是谎言，字面意义上的谎言，这真的让我很沮丧，人际因素让我很沮丧。
Yeah, there was an article written in this old paper in LA, I don't even think they printed anymore, called the LA Weekly, this is like, I don't know, 30 years ago, that's like a cover story called The Fine Art of Lying. And talking about the relevance and the necessity of it, specifically in the entertainment industry, I'm sure it's pervasive in other industries as well, but specifically that they cited all these examples.
是的，洛杉矶的一家老报纸上曾登过一篇文章，我甚至觉得他们现在都不印了，叫《洛杉矶周刊》，大概是，我不知道，30年前的事了，那是一个封面故事，叫做《说谎的艺术》。谈到了说谎的相关性和必要性，特别是在娱乐行业，我确信它在其他行业也很普遍，但特别指出他们引用了所有这些例子。
And it's really true, I become sort of immune or sort of numb to it, But if you really think about it, if you think about your conversations with your team, with the other people that you work with, there is a level of lying that I myself do as well, that you kind of have to do just to protect the people's feelings that you love in this business. Cause there's so much rejection,
这真的很真实，我变得有点免疫或者说有点麻木了。但如果你真的去想它，如果你想想你与你的团队、与和你一起工作的其他人的对话，确实存在一定程度的谎言，我自己也会这样做，为了保护你在这个行业中所爱的人的感情，你某种程度上不得不这么做。因为有那么多的拒绝，
there's so much sort of, yeah, it's not a fit, blah, blah, blah, that you have to, if you're empathetic at all, reshape and sort of tell what I like to think are white lies. But you do have to get used to it. I don't know, you do get used to it, but I don't think that you are, or numb to it. I mean, I know, for example-
有那么多的，是的，不合适，诸如此类，如果你还有一点同理心，你就得重塑，并且说一些我喜欢认为的善意的谎言。但你确实必须习惯它。我不知道，你确实会习惯它，但我不认为你是，或者对它麻木了。我是说，我知道，比方说——
But what do you mean lies about what? Well, lies about your, hey, I saw, but what do you mean lies about what? Like, well lies about your, your, hey, oh, I, I saw your movie the other day. Oh yeah, what'd you think? Now, if you didn't like it, but your friend's at that person. Now, obviously this is not some big thing that I'm revealing, but there is sort of a, I find that there is a lot of it that you need to do in this town
但你指的谎言是什么？好吧，关于你的谎言，嘿，我看到，但你指的谎言是什么？比如，关于你的，你的，嘿，哦，我，我前几天看了你的电影。哦，是吗？你觉得怎么样？现在，如果你不喜欢，但你的朋友就是那个人。现在，显然这不是什么我透露的重大秘密，但我发现你在镇上确实需要做很多这种事，
if you care about the people that you're talking to because there's so much rejection. Yeah, everybody works hard. And the difference of opinion, yeah. By the way, I, for what it's worth, I loved Good Night Oscar. Oh yes, and me. I think I liked it more.
如果你在乎跟你说话的人的话，因为有太多的拒绝。是的，每个人都很努力。而且观点不同，是的。顺便说一句，不管值多少钱，我很喜欢《晚安，奥斯卡》。哦，是的，我也是。我想我更喜欢它。
I loved it a lot, Shawn, I thought you were so good at it. Oh, Shawn, so gifted. I loved it. Good Night Oscar, what a tribute. And we will be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. If I had an extra hour of my day, I'd probably either take a nap or go for a walk.
肖恩，我非常喜欢，我觉得你演得太好了。哦，肖恩，太有天赋了。我很喜欢。《晚安，奥斯卡》，真是致敬之作。我们马上回来。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。如果我的一天能多出一小时，我可能会选择小睡一会儿或者去散步。
Why those two things? Because they clear my head, they make me feel better, I can think easier, I can connect with people easier, and I'm in a better mood. And so for you guys, I would ask, the question is time for what? If time was unlimited, how would you use it? How would you decide what's important enough
为什么是这两件事？因为它们能让我头脑清醒，让我感觉更好，思考更轻松，与人交流更轻松，而且心情更好。所以对你们大家，我想问的问题是：时间留给什么？如果时间是无限的，你会怎么利用它？你如何决定什么是足够重要，
to make time for? Therapy can help you find what matters to you so you can do more of it. I've benefited from therapy for a long time now. I can't express to you guys enough how much greatness I get from it, how much better I feel, how much better other people see that I feel.
值得为之腾出时间的？治疗可以帮助你找到对你真正重要的东西，这样你就可以做更多这样的事。很长一段时间以来，我都受益于心理治疗。我无法向你们充分表达我从中获得了多少伟大之处，我感觉有多好，别人看到我感觉有多好。
It's good all the way around. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Learn to make time for what makes
这各方面都很好。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在方便、灵活并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。学会为那些让你
you happy with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelphelp.com slash smartlist. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartLess. Get buckets with your first bet on FanDuel America's number one sports book because right now new customers get $150 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's $150 if your bet wins. Within the app, you have the ability to bet on all your favorite NBA players and teams with QuickBets, live same-game parlays, exclusive props, and more. You know, I wish we could take bets on how quickly Jason and or will teams with quick bets, live same game parlays, exclusive props and more. You know, I wish we could take bets on how quickly Jason and or will will bring up the subject of golf, like, you know, to the second.
快乐的事腾出时间，就从 BetterHelp 开始。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartlist，你的第一个月可享 10% 的折扣。网址是 betterhelphelp.com/smartlist。感谢 FanDuel 赞助本期 SmartLess 节目。在 FanDuel 上用你的第一笔投注赢取奖金，这里是美国第一大体育博彩公司，因为现在新客户只要有任何赢利的 5 美元投注，就能获得 150 美元的奖金投注。如果你的投注获胜，就能获得 150 美元。在应用程序内，你可以通过快速投注、同场串关直播、独家道具等功能，对你所有最喜欢的 NBA 球员和球队进行投注。你知道的，我希望我们能打赌，杰森和/或威尔带出高尔夫话题的速度有多快，比如说，精确到秒。
So like, I would say like, I bet you it's going to be two minutes, 32 seconds before they talk about golf. That'd be fun, right? Doesn't everybody feel like they'd win at some point if we just kept betting on it? Anyway, just visit fandual.com slash smartlist and shoot your shot. Fandual, official sportsbook partner of the NBA, 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. This episode of smart list is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Hey guys, looking for some excitement in 2024?
所以我可能会说，我打赌他们会在两分三十二秒内开始聊高尔夫。那会很有趣，对吧？如果我们就一直押注，难道每个人不都觉得自己会在某个时刻赢吗？不管怎样，只需访问 fandual.com/smartlist，勇敢一试。FanDuel 是 NBA 的官方体育博彩合作伙伴，21岁及以上，适用相关限制条款。完整免责声明请参阅节目说明。本期 SmartLess 节目部分由 Skinny Pop 爆米花赞助播出。嘿，各位，在 2024 年寻找一些刺激吗？
Check out Skinny Pop's new cheddar jalapeno popcorn made with real cheddar cheese and a pop of jalapeno. This new flavor is sure to spice up your daily snacking routine. So Scott and I started this thing called Movies That Rule. It's a movie night. We have some friends over and he created this whole trailer thing with like on his computer. I don't know how he did it. And and it's this trailer like all these upcoming movies and then we watched this great like classic movie and we were like well
快来看看 Skinny Pop 推出的全新切达墨西哥辣椒爆米花，采用真正的切达干酪和少许墨西哥辣椒制作而成。这款新口味一定会为你的日常零食时间增添辛辣刺激。所以斯科蒂和我发起了一项名为“伟大的电影”的活动。这是一个电影之夜。我们邀请一些朋友过来，他在电脑上制作了整个预告片什么的。我不知道他是怎么做到的。它就像一个包含所有即将上映电影的预告片，然后我们观看了这部精彩的经典电影，我们当时就想，
what do we got for the people that come over what we're gonna get skinny pop we got we really truly got skinny pop we put bowls and bowls of it out it just made movies that rule night even that much better a deliciously simple combination of popcorn oil and salt every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more skinny pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, staving off boredom or unwinding after a long day. In addition to the original popcorn,
我们为过来的人准备了什么，我们要买 Skinny Pop，我们真的买了很多 Skinny Pop，我们把一碗又一碗的爆米花摆出来，它让“伟大的电影”之夜变得更加美好。由爆米花、油和盐完美组合而成，美味可口，每一口他们完美爆开的原味爆米花都让你回味无穷。Skinny Pop 轻盈美味，适合任何场合，无论你是在路上、赶走无聊，还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。除了原味爆米花，
Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle. And I'm telling you, just by the title alone, the Cheddar Jalapeño Popcorn, I can't wait to try it. Shop Skinny Pop now. jalapeno popcorn, I can't wait to try it. Shop skinny pop now. All right, back to the show. But Kelly, I was gonna say,
Skinny Pop 还提供各种美味的选择，从白切达干酪到香甜可口的焦糖壶烧。我跟你说，光是凭名字里的“切达墨西哥辣椒爆米花”，我就迫不及待想尝尝了。现在就购买 Skinny Pop。墨西哥辣椒爆米花，我迫不及待想尝尝了。现在就购买 Skinny Pop。好的，回到节目中。但是凯莉，我正想说，
well, you know, you touch on something which is, but, and kind of actually going on what Sean said, which is that you belong, there is that feeling of like, you, I think a lot of Americans identified with you because you were the first person who kind of was plucked out of a blim I think a lot of Americans identified with you because you were the first person who kind of was plucked out of a blim and became a superstar. And I guess that's what I'm wondering about is, after that you are, because people felt a certain sense
你知道，你触及了一个点，就是，而且其实顺着肖恩的话说，就是你属于这里，有一种感觉，你，我觉得很多美国人对你产生共鸣，因为你是第一个从一个小地方被发掘出来，我觉得很多美国人对你产生共鸣，因为你是第一个从一个小地方被发掘出来，并成为超级巨星的人。我想我好奇的是，在那之后你是，因为人们对你有一种
of ownership of you. And a proxy of like the American dream. Yeah, yeah. So how hard is that? That's not hard. Like that's not, I mean, I get that. I don't know how, but I still like, I can still like be objective and go,
所有权的感觉。而且是美国梦的化身。是的，是的。那有多难？那不难。那不是，我的意思是，我懂。我不知道怎么做到的，但我仍然喜欢，我仍然可以保持客观并说，
man, that's incredible that someone made it in that sense. Like, you know what I'm saying? Like, you know, and it kind of, I think what it did just for speaking to people and meet and greet and whatnot for years and years is it really gave people like a, I don't know what, like a, it kind of gave people that thing of like,
天哪，有人能在那种意义上成功，这太不可思议了。就像，你知道我在说什么吗？就像，你知道的，它有点，我想它多年来通过与人们的见面会等等，真正给人们带来了一种，我不知道是什么，就像，它有点给人们那种感觉，
no, really you can't accomplish anything. Like your dreams and whatever it is, you could actually make this happen. Like this person was from nowhere, like a cocktail address, like, you know, nowhere near making it. And they actually film that stuff, right? They like, they deliver your story too too much like they do in the Olympics.
不，真的，你没有什么不能完成的。你的梦想和无论什么，你真的可以实现。这个人来自荒郊野岭，就像一个鸡尾酒吧地址，就像，离成功十万八千里。他们真的把那些东西拍下来了，对吧？他们太像奥运会那样讲述你的故事了。
They deliver your story to, and then boom, they go live. Here's her singing on stage. Yeah, and I think people relate to that. I think people think maybe I can still do that, or maybe that could be me. I think that it has this sense of hope with it. Aspirational, yeah, yeah, yeah. Vicarious, yeah.
他们把你的故事呈现出来，然后轰的一声，他们开始直播。这是她在舞台上唱歌。是的，我觉得人们对此很有共鸣。我觉得人们会想，也许我还能做到，或者那也许可以是我。我觉得这其中带着一种希望。令人向往的，是的，是的，是的。神往的，是的。
Yeah, well, Shawn, you used to do a lot of meet and beats, right? Yeah, I used to do it. No, no, no, sorry. She said meet and greet. Well, OK. Sorry. Yeah. Sorry.
是的，好吧，肖恩，你以前做过很多粉丝见面会，对吧？是的，我以前做过。不，不，不，抱歉。她说的是见面会。好吧，没关系。抱歉。是的。
Well done. Good for you, Sean. Thank you, Joe. So listen, do you remember when you first started immersing yourself into the world of Hollywood and Los Angeles and all that? Do you remember what was kind of foreign to you that you were like, oh, I didn't know you needed makeup every single time.
干得好。真为你高兴，肖恩。谢谢你，乔。听着，你还记得当你第一次开始融入好莱坞、洛杉矶以及所有这些世界的时候吗？你还记得有什么对你来说挺陌生的，让你觉得，哦，我不知道每次都需要化妆。
I don't know. Oh, I got in trouble on American Idol. They were, they were like, so we're about to be on camera. And I was like, I know. And they were like, but you're going to be on camera. And I was like, I know. And then it was like, okay, well, do you want any like makeup or hair? And I was like, no, I'm in a house right now.
我不知道。哦，我在《美国偶像》惹麻烦了。他们说，我们要上镜头了。我说，我知道。他们说，但你要上镜头。我说，我知道。然后他们就说，好吧，那你想要点妆容或发型吗？我说，不用，我现在在家里。
You're doing like behind the scenes. Like I was like, I'm not on stage. Like I was like, I mean, I'll do it for stage. I was like, but why are we doing this now? The one producer in particular, very high up, was not a fan of me just because I didn't play that game. And it wasn't even playing the game. Like the other four girls that season were very into,
你在做幕后那种。就像我说，我又不在舞台上。就像我说，好吧，我会为舞台化妆的。我说，但我们现在为什么要弄这个？其中一位制作人特别高层，非常不喜欢我，就因为我没有玩那套游戏。甚至都不是玩游戏，那一季的其他四个女孩非常喜欢，
you know, that stuff. They were very into it. The glam of it, yeah. Yeah, I was like the most amazing person to tour with for those girls, because I was never in the makeup and hair chair. Like I was like, they would have to be forced me to like sit there.
你知道，那些东西。她们非常喜欢。那种魅力，对吧。对，对那些女孩来说，我是最棒的巡演伙伴，因为我从不坐在化妆和发型椅上。就像我一样，她们不得不强迫我坐在那里。
Cause I'm highly allergic. Anything that gets near my eyes, vegan, whoever's brand that says whatever, it still sucks for my eyes. And anyway, so I don't like wearing it. I don't enjoy wearing it. And so that was a big thing. You can't pry me out of the chair, you know?
因为我严重过敏。任何靠近我眼睛的东西，纯素的，不管是哪个品牌的标签写着什么，对我的眼睛来说都很糟糕。总之，所以我不喜欢戴。我不喜欢戴。所以那是一件大事。你休想把我从椅子上拉开，你知道吗？
Yeah, no. I need it. Well, and that's the thing. I adore the people I work with. Even my makeup artist. I love her so much. I was laughing at Jason saying you often like stare directly in their eyes to make it.
是的，不。我需要它。好吧，就是这样。我非常喜欢和我一起工作的人。甚至我的化妆师。我太喜欢她了。我笑杰森说你经常直视他们的眼睛来让它。
We have so many like inside, it's such an intimate setting. Like we're such close friends just because of that. Like, you know, but so I love, I love, you know, the art of it. I love how creative people can be. It's just not my thing. Right, right. So then you, so you don't do it
我们有那么多内部的东西，这是一个非常亲密的场景。我们是如此亲密的朋友，就因为那个。就像，你知道的，所以我喜欢，我喜欢，你知道，它的艺术性。我喜欢人们能有多么富有创造力。只是这不适合我。对，对。所以你，所以你不做
or you're sort of resistant to it for all the reasons you just outlined. Then you win American Idol. Now you're a pop star and now you've got to release record after record which you do incredibly successfully. So just talk to us a little bit about that. And singing in front of thousands of people.
或者你出于刚才列举的所有原因对它有点抗拒。然后你赢得了《美国偶像》。现在你是一个流行歌星，现在你必须一张接一张地发行唱片，你做得很极其成功。所以跟我们多聊聊这个。还有在几千人面前唱歌。
Exactly. I'm fascinated by, all of a sudden, now you're a mega star sort of overnight, not really. Now of course, people don't realize that you've been working for years trying to do it. You want to do it. Yeah, but it was overnight. I'm okay with that.
没错。我很着迷于，突然之间，你一夜之间就成了一个巨星，其实也不算。现在当然，人们没有意识到你为了做到这一点已经努力了好几年。你想这么做。是的，但确实是一夜之间。我接受这一点。
Okay, and then, thank you for letting me off the hook. And then you, but then you all of a sudden, it's like, okay, so you win, that's huge. And now you got to record a record, right? You got to make a, you go right into making a record. Is that how it went? Yeah, and it was bumpy from the beginning. Yeah, just because nobody knew what to do with me
好的，然后，谢谢你放过我。然后你，但然后你突然间，就像，好吧，你赢了，这很大。现在你得录制一张唱片，对吧？你得做个，你马上就开始做唱片。事情是这样的吗？是的，而且从一开始就很坎坷。是的，就因为没有人知道怎么把我塑造成型
cause I liked a lot of different genres of music and everybody kind of had a different plan and nobody knew that it would be successful in their defense. You know, they didn't, you know, they were like, yeah, this kid from this show, like I understand that and understood it then as well, by the way. But it was a little bumpy, and then people don't know this, but it wasn't Clive right
因为我喜欢许多不同种类的音乐，每个人都有不同的计划，而且出于为他们辩护的考虑，没有人知道这会成功。你知道，他们不知道，你知道，他们会想，是的，这个节目出来的孩子，我当时也理解，顺便说一句。但这有点坎坷，然后人们不知道这一点，但当时不是克莱夫，对吧
off the bat. There was another person running the label. Clive Davis, yeah. Yeah, it wasn't him running the label. I didn't make my first record with him. So anyway, it was just kind of rocky from the beginning. There was a changing of hands, like a baton passing with the label. There's a lot going on.
马上。当时有另一个人在运营唱片公司。克莱夫·戴维斯，对。是的，不是他在运营唱片公司。我和他并没有合作我的第一张唱片。所以不管怎样，从一开始事情就有点波折。唱片公司经历了一次权力交接，就像传递接力棒一样。有很多事情在发生。
Nobody knew what to do. Like it was crazy. Like I think people thought, oh, right off the bat, she had all this money to do it. No, everybody was plugging in our own gear at State Fair's and cow shit and doing State Fair. Like we were like, it wasn't right off the bat. Who was producing the record for you then?
没有人知道该怎么做。感觉太疯狂了。我觉得人们以为，哦，她一开始就有那么多钱来做这件事。不，每个人都在州立集市上自己插电设备，站在牛粪上，去参加州立集市。就像我们那样，根本不是一开始就很顺利。那当时是谁在为你制作唱片呢？
At that point, who are you? Like what was that process? I can't remember, I think it was Peterson. I can't remember his name. It was a long time ago, but he was right in the beginning, he was very nice, like right in the beginning, I'd met him once. And really it was just us in the studio and they were kind of setting me up with different producers
到那个时候，你是谁？或者说那个过程是怎样的？我记不清了，我想是彼得森。我记不清他叫什么名字了。那是很久以前的事了，但他一开始人很好，真的就在一开始，我见过他一次。实际上就是我们在录音室里，他们给我安排了不同的制作人
and different writers and stuff. And did you write these songs? Or were these songs that were written by, because a lot of artists I've learned very late in life, some of them write their own music and they perform their music and then others, no better, no worse, they take songs that are already written by somebody who doesn't know how to sing and then they sing. Didn't you sing an Aver Levine song?
和不同的词曲作者之类的。这些歌是你写的吗？还是由别人写的，因为很多艺人，我是生活到了很晚才明白，他们中的一些人自己创作音乐，自己表演音乐，而另一些人——没有高低优劣之分——他们演唱别人写的歌，而那些人自己不会唱歌。你不是唱过艾薇儿·拉维尼的歌吗？
Yeah, I've sang a Katie's song, Christina's song, Sia, Pink, Ever. I love writing, and I've been writing since my first album. I've always written on my records, and I've also always just loved finding songs that I feel like I was intended to be the vessel for. Like, I love, I mean, I love interpretation. So, I mean, obviously, even from the talk show, if we skip ahead, like, I love taking a song and even flipping it, like, the production. I just, I love storytelling. I don't flipping it like the production. I just I love storytelling
对，我唱过凯莉的歌、克里斯蒂娜的歌、希雅、粉妈，唱过很多。我热爱创作，从我的第一张专辑开始我就一直在写歌。我的专辑里一直都有我写的歌，而且我也一直很喜欢寻找那些让我觉得我生来就该作为其载体的歌曲。我喜欢，我是说，我喜欢演绎。所以，显然，甚至从脱口秀节目来看，如果我们快进一下，我喜欢拿一首歌甚至把它颠覆一下，比如编曲。我就是，我喜欢讲故事。我就是不喜欢把它颠覆成编曲那样。我只是我喜欢讲故事
I don't like acting in the way of storytelling. I like watching it but I like singing and acting in that sense and and with storytelling and That that's always been like a love of mine. So I've done both since the very beginning Sorry, what do you ever see a movie called into the woods? I'd love that that yeah Sorry, Sean, did you ever see a movie called Into the Woods? I'd love that movie. Yeah, with Maelstrom, Emily Blunt, James Cooke. Like would you ever be excited if somebody
我不喜欢那种像演戏一样的讲故事。我喜欢看那种表演，但我喜欢那种意义上的唱歌和演戏，通过讲故事的方式——那一直以来都是我的最爱。所以从一开始我就两样都在做。抱歉，你有没有看过一部叫《魔法黑森林》的电影？我超喜欢那部——对。抱歉，肖恩，你有没有看过一部电影叫《魔法黑森林》？我超喜欢那部电影。对，有梅丽尔·斯特里普、艾米莉·布朗特、詹姆斯·柯登。你会不会也对别人
brought you something like that, where there's a little bit of acting, but a lot of singing as well, like singing acting? Also known as a musical movie. Go ahead, Jason. Also known as a musical. You know there's a whole genre. Based on a musical.
拿给你这种作品感到兴奋，既有一点表演，又有大量的演唱，也就是歌唱表演？也就是所谓的音乐剧电影。说吧，杰森。也就是所谓的音乐剧。你知道有一个专门的流派。改编自音乐剧。
The guy named Steven Sondheim I hear is really something to take off. He's gonna make it. He's up and if it was a musical. The guy named Steven Sondheim I hear is really starting to take off. He's gonna make it. He's up and coming up. Jason, Jason, do some singing acting for us real quick. Yeah. Hello, I'm hungry. Nice.
我听说有个叫斯蒂芬·桑德海姆的家伙真的很了不起。他要成功了。他正在崭露——如果这是一部音乐剧的话。我听说有个叫斯蒂芬·桑德海姆的家伙真的很开始崭露头角。他要成功了。他正在崭露头角。杰森，杰森，快给我们来一段歌唱表演。好。你好，我饿了。不错。
Is there something like that? You can sing, Jason. Well, that's not acting, because we know you're hungry. Yeah. So. I would maybe do something like that, but I think I'm like such a fan of what y'all can do.
有类似这样的东西吗？你会唱歌的，杰森。好吧，那不算演戏，因为我们知道你饿了。对。所以。我可能会做类似的事情，但我感觉我非常崇拜你们能做到的事情。
Like I think it's interesting when actors, especially I have in this talk show, like I meet actors a lot and I never was around actors, only musicians generally. And we're always like looking at the other pasture. Like everybody said it's always greener. You know, everybody's like, oh my God, I'm such a fan of what you do.
我觉得很有趣的是，当演员们——特别是通过这个脱口秀，我经常遇到演员，而我以前从不跟演员接触，通常只有音乐人。我们总是看着对方的草坪。每个人都觉得草总是绿的。你知道，每个人都说，哦天哪，我太崇拜你做的事情了。
It's so like what y'all do is incredible to me. The fact that you can run lines like that, do the same emotion over and over again, whatever it's serious or funny or whatever. And it doesn't wear you out or get monotonous is beyond to me. I feel the same way about musicians. I do, I'm in awe of what you do, your ability to.
这太像了，你们做的事情对我来说太不可思议了。你们能够那样顺下台词，一遍又一遍地表现出相同的感情，不管是严肃的、搞笑的还是别的什么。而且这不会让你筋疲力尽或感到单调，这对我来说简直难以想象。我对音乐人也有同样的感受。真的，我对你们所做的事情叹为观止，你们有能力去——
No, but I find that that's the case, right? So I, but I have such an appreciation for it. And I've never like, like I did know the winner of American Idol, we found I did know the winner of American Idol. We found out, like, around the top five, that in that little fine print that we signed for the contract, the winner would have to do this movie. And I was, I literally have cried, like, so hard
不，但我发现事实就是这样，对吧？所以，我，但我对此非常感激。我从来没有像——我确实知道《美国偶像》的冠军是谁，我们发现——我确实知道《美国偶像》的冠军是谁。我们发现，大约在进前五名的时候，在我们签合同的那些小字条款里，冠军必须拍这部电影。我字面意义上哭得——超厉害
to get out of that. Like, because I did not want to do it. I did not think it was good. Neither did anyone else. And I did not want to act like that. Like that was not my goal. Did you? Did you have to? Yeah.
想推掉那个。因为我根本不想拍。我觉得它一点也不好。其他人也这么觉得。我才不想那样演戏。那根本不是我的目标。你呢？你必须得去吗？对。
I bought the first ticket. I was right in the theater. I had to do it, yeah. And it's not like I was like trying to, you know, poo poo on it or whatever. It's just, I was so worried because my goal was to sing and tour and do stuff like that. And so I was so worried that it was going to ruin any chance of me being taken seriously as an artist.
我买了第一张票。我当时就在影院里。我必须得拍，是的。并不是说我当时想去，你知道的，贬低它什么的。只是，我太担心了，因为我的目标是唱歌、巡演以及做类似的事情。所以我非常担心这会毁掉我作为一名艺人被认真对待的任何机会。
So I begged my label to at least let me put my single out. Like just let me get a single out. Let me have a chance, like before this comes out. And they did. So that, I think that's what saved me was a single out. Let me have a chance, like before this comes out. And they did. So that, I think that's what saved me was that first single. What level of pride do you allow yourself to feel that you have taken in what, 20 years, a great step through a door
所以我恳求我的唱片公司至少让我把单曲发出去。就让我发首单曲吧。给我一个机会，在这部电影上映之前。他们确实同意了。所以，我想是那首单曲拯救了我。单曲发出去。给我一个机会，在这部电影上映之前。他们确实同意了。所以，我想是那首单曲拯救了我。对于你自己在20年的时间里，跨过了这扇不是由别人为你推开的门，你允许自己感到多大程度的自豪？我的意思是，那部分也是你完成的。但是一旦你有了这个平台，以及所有你以此为基础建立并使其多元化的资本，并将它转化为如此庞大、正当的事业，以至于有些人会非常好奇地听说你是从《美国偶像》出道的。这有点像，你知道的，
that wasn't pride open for you by anybody else? I mean, you did that part too. But once you had that platform and all this capital that you were able to build on it, diversify it, and parlay it into this massive, legitimate career such that some people would be really interested to hear that you got started on American Idol. It's much the same way, like, you know,
有这么多从《明星搜寻》出道的人。就好像，等等，什么？对，有很多买你唱片的孩子并没有看你在《偶像》里的表现，对吧，杰？这就是你的意思吗？就像有很多你的粉丝根本不知道那件事一样？
there's all these people that started on Star Search. It's like, wait, what? Yeah, there are a lot of kids who bought your records who didn't watch you on Idol, right, Jay? Is that where you're getting at? Like there are a lot of people who are fans of yours who don't know that. Exactly, and my question is, do you,
没错，我的问题是，你——
have you sort of just out of admirable humility lost? Are you allowed to feel, do you allow yourself to feel the pride that I think you deserve, that you've done so much with that moment that frankly some others have not from American Idol or any of the other shows? Yeah, I mean, I think for me, what I'm most proud of is even if there's like, I've been told in this business
是不是出于一种令人钦佩的谦逊而把某种东西丢掉了？你是否允许自己去感受那种我认为你应得的自豪——你用那个时刻做成了那么多事情，坦白讲，其他一些人从《美国偶像》或任何其他选秀节目出来后并没有做到这一点？是的，我的意思是，对我来说，我最自豪的是，即使有——我在这一行里听人说过
like, well, you're a sinking ship, you know, and I was like, okay, cool, but as long as I'm at the helm, I'm cool with that. Like as long as somebody else isn't driving it, like that's cool. Like I think that's what I take pride in is like, look, I have as I've been a perfect career, it's obviously been like this, but like,
比如，“嗯，你是一艘沉船，”你知道的，我就说，“好吧，挺酷的，但只要我是掌舵的人，我就觉得没问题。”只要不是别人在开船，那就挺酷的。我觉得这就是我引以为傲的地方：看吧，我的职业生涯算完美吗？显然经历过起起伏伏，但是——
it's been perfect for me in the sense of like, every decision I've made and everything I've done, it's because I wanted to do it regardless of the outcome. And I think I'm proud of the fact that I don't let pride or ego or even shame if that comes in, you know, at some point when something, you know, or any of that, I don't let that get in the way of it. So how did you, how did you learn that? Because you were like you said, 19 and now you're 40, whatever.
它对我来说是完美的，因为我做出的每一个决定和做的每一件事，都是因为我想这么做，而不管结果如何。我感到骄傲的是，我不会让骄傲、自我，甚至羞耻感——如果当某个时刻发生时，你知道的，或者诸如此类的任何情绪涌上心头——我不会让这些东西妨碍我。那么你是如何，你是如何学会这一点的？因为你正如你所说，当时19岁，而现在你40岁还是多少岁。
How did you learn how to weed out the good from the bad as you entered the business? Childhood trauma. I think, no, I honestly, that's why people always ask me about my kids and being in the business. I'm like, I'm good for them if they want to do it. I just think because of how I was set up from a very young person and like,
当你进入这个行业时，你是如何学会去芜存菁的？童年创伤。我觉得，不，说实话，这就是为什么人们总是问我关于我的孩子和进入这个行业的事。我会说，如果他们想做，我挺支持的。我只是觉得，因为我从小所受的经历，以及——
and hearing the things that happened or whatever my life happened and having to navigate that, I think definitely prepared me for the industry and prepared me for a spotlight to be okay to be me, like regardless if you're into it or not. Everybody likes something different, artist subjective, but I think that is fucked up as that sounds.
听到那些发生的事情或我生命中发生的其他事情，以及不得不去应对这些，我认为这绝对让我为这个行业做好了准备，也为聚光灯做好了准备，让我能够安于做自己——不管你是不是喜欢。每个人喜欢的东西都不同，艺术是主观的，但我觉得，尽管听起来很操蛋，
I think a lot of the traumatic things that happened to me when I was younger really not only built a thicker skin, but I think it also, when you, let's say you hear from someone that's supposed to love you the most, you know what I'm saying in life? And you're like, you didn't quite, that you weren't good enough? I think that when that happens, you're like, well didn't quite, that you weren't good enough. I think that when that happens,
我觉得我年轻时经历的许多创伤，不仅帮我练就了更厚脸皮，而且我觉得，当你——比方说你从一个本该最爱你的人那里听到那样的话，你知道我在生活中指的是什么吗？然后你会觉得，你不够好？我觉得当那种事发生时，你会觉得，或者并没有完全达到要求，你不够好？我觉得当那种事发生时，
you're like, well, I'm never gonna please anyone. So like, why even aim for it? I'm just gonna have a good time. Like, okay, I'm just gonna like do what I love to do. Interesting. And cause you know, when that person that, or people that are supposed to be there for you the most, like when you get let down, and I know that sounds dark,
你会觉得，好吧，我永远无法取悦任何人。所以，为什么还要去强求呢？我只要过得开心就好。好吧，我只想做我喜欢做的事。有趣。因为你知道，当那个本该支持你的人，或者本该最支持你的人——当你受到打击时，我知道这听起来很黑暗，
but when that happens, I think in your head, you're like, okay, well then, maybe life isn't so about just aiming to please everyone or aiming to receive something. Maybe you just do it because you wanna do it and you never know how many trips around the sun you get. You might as well try whatever you want. Yeah, I think the same way.
但当那种事发生时，我想你的脑海里会想，好吧，那么，也许生命并不全在于去取悦所有人或试图去得到什么。也许你做一件事只是因为你想做，而且你永远不知道自己还能绕着太阳转多少圈。你大可以去尝试任何你想做的事。是的，我也是这么想的。
I mean, or maybe even said differently if you agree that it sets you up, the necessity becomes being self-sufficient. If you can't rely on those closest to you at certain times, then you learn, well, then I just have to make myself happy. I've got that. Yeah, it's like survival. Yeah, and it's because I was gonna say,
我是说，或者换一种说法如果你同意的话，它迫使你变得自力更生。如果在某些时刻你无法依靠最亲近的人，那么你就会明白，好吧，那我就只能让自己快乐。我能搞定。是的，这就好比求生。是的，而且因为我正要说，
and Sean beat me to the question, like you are so clearly comfortable in your skin and you know, shitty word, I don't have a better one, but you're just lovely. And like, well, you know. I'm kidding, I'm kidding. I love the word. But like who, I was gonna ask you,
肖恩抢先问了我的问题——你整个人表现得如此坦然而自在，你知道的，虽然这是个糟糕的词，我找不到更好的，但你就是非常可人。而且，嗯，你知道的。我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的。我很喜欢这个词。但话说回来，我正要问你，
who can you attribute that to? I mean, do you have? Yeah, like, because you didn't become a drug addict. You didn't become this or that. Yeah, did you have great parents or parent or uncle or something that really showed you kind of this North Star of like, well, wow, look at the adversity they've gone through
这一切你要归功于谁？我是说，你有什么？是的，因为你没有吸毒。你没有变成这样或那样的人。是的，你是否有很好的父母、某位家长、叔叔或其他什么人，真正向你展示了某种北极星般的指引——哇，看看他们经历过怎样的逆境，
and they're still able to be, you know, loving and giving and warm and open to the people they care about and they're not walking around and bitter and aggrieved. And like it's just, you seem to really have taken whatever negatives you went through and I'm not prying for those, but you seem to have turned them into a positive
而他们依然能够对他们关心的人保持关爱、慷慨、温暖和开放，他们没有终日怨天尤人、苦大仇深。这就好像，你似乎真的把你经历过的任何负面情绪——我不是在打听那些事——但你似乎把它们转化为了正面的力量，
and they just taught you coping mechanisms that have yielded this nice balanced personality and vibe. It seems like, yeah. Yeah, I think for me, it wasn't like one person. That's our time. Thank you so much Kelly. That's great. That, I think for me it wasn't one person.
它们教给了你应对机制，从而铸就了你这种愉快而平衡的个性和气场。看起来确实如此，是的。是的，我觉得对我来说，那不是某一个人的功劳。我们的时间到了。非常感谢你，凯莉。太棒了。那个，我觉得对我来说那不是某一个人的功劳。
I think it's a village, right? That raises any kid. Like I don't think it's, you know, people are like, oh, it's my mom or it's my dad or it's, you know, whatever. I think obviously that probably is true, but I also think we are raised by our surroundings, regardless of your teachers, your coaches, and sports,
我觉得抚养任何一个孩子都需要全村之力，对吧？我不认为那是，你知道，人们会说，哦，是我妈妈，或者是我爸爸，或者是，你知道的，诸如此类。我觉得这可能确实是真的，但我也认为我们是由我们的成长环境所抚养长大的，不论是你的老师、教练、体育界的人，
like all your other friends' parents. And I think for some reason, I don't know why or how, but I don't know, I kind of navigated people in a sense of like, I'm gonna take the, I love that part of you. That's a really cool thing. I don't in a sense of like, I'm gonna take the, I love that part of you. Like that's a really cool thing. Like I don't have a lot of positive experiences for this one person in my life that I won't mention.
还是你所有其他朋友的父母。我觉得出于某种原因，我不知道为什么或如何做到的，但我不知道，我接触人的方式是这样的：我要吸收——我喜欢你身上那一点。那真的是一件很酷的事。我不是在那种意义上——我要吸收——我喜欢你身上那一点。就像那真的是一件很酷的事。我对生命中我不会提及的这个人并没有很多积极的体验。
But the one thing I will say for them is they were always highly complimentary of people, even if it was fake or whatever for them. But growing up, I saw how it made people feel. And I was like, oh, that's lovely for lack of a better word. That's like to make someone feel. And I stole that like for my person. And I was like, I was like, I like that.
但我能为他们说的唯一一件事是，他们总是高度赞美别人，哪怕那对他们来说是虚假的或其他什么。但在我成长过程中，我看到那能让别人作何感受。我就想，用缺一个更好的词来形容的话，这感觉真好。让人有这种感觉真好。我把那个偷学过来放到了我身上，我就觉得，我挺喜欢那个。
I like to make people feel like that. I like to compliment people. But you know what, Kelly, there's a real wisdom to that, which is, and Sean, you always say it takes a village people, but you know, we, you, there's a wisdom to this idea that you, whatever you put wisdom to this idea that you, whatever you put out in life is what you're gonna get back, right?
我喜欢让别人有那种感觉。我喜欢赞美别人。但你知道吗，凯莉，这里面蕴含着真正的智慧，那就是——肖恩，你总是说“抚养一个孩子需要全村之力”，但你知道，我们，你，这里面蕴含着这样一种智慧，那就是你，无论你把智慧倾注到这个想法中，你在生活中付出什么，就会收获什么，对吧？
And so, I have no idea who you're talking about or what they're like as a person. They might be a terrible person, but at least in that aspect. They work great. And if you, yeah, so if you, you know, sometimes that feeling of loving somebody, no matter what,
所以，我不知道你在说谁，也不知道他们作为一个人是什么样的。他们可能是个糟糕的人，但至少在这方面。他们做得很棒。如果你，是的，所以如果你，你知道，有时候那种无论如何都要去爱某一个人的感觉，
will increase the chances of you getting love back. And that feeling of hurt or whatever comes from a lack of actually putting love out. And I think that there's a balance there. There's like a, and when it comes to people too, you sort of start to identify, I know that as I get older, I identify the people in my life where I go, I make a conscious effort to surround myself
会增加你获得爱的几率。而那种受伤的感觉或其他什么，则来自于没有真正去付出爱。我觉得这里面存在一种平衡。这里面有一种，而且当涉及到人际关系时，你开始辨认出——我知道随着年龄的增长，我开始辨认出我生活中的那些人，我会对自己说，我有意识地让自己周围围绕着
and to spend time with people that I love and I know love me. And then my experience is better. These guys on this, you know, here with us today are two great examples. I probably don't spend more time with anybody than these two guys, you know, in my sort of, and because I love them and they love me.
并花时间与我爱并且我也知道他们爱我的人在一起。然后我的体验就会变得更好。今天和我们在一起的这两位老兄就是两个很好的例子。我花时间和除了这两位以外的人在一起的时间可能都不多，你知道的，在我的生活中，因为我爱他们，他们也爱我。
And so that's a positive experience. Exactly, yeah. We'll be right back. We'd like to thank Helix for supporting the show. You know, we always talk about how great these mattresses are, these Helix mattresses, and how great it is to get some sleep on them. But I have to tell you how great it is
所以那是一种积极的体验。没错，是的。我们马上回来。我们要感谢Helix对节目的支持。你知道，我们总是谈论这些床垫有多棒，这些Helix床垫，以及在它们上面睡觉有多舒服。但我必须告诉你，
to be awake reading a book on them. It's so comfortable. It's like you're sinking into like this beautiful soft cloud and it makes whatever you're reading just a little bit more cozy and comfortable. I love it. I love doing that. I love reading on a Helix mattress.
在上面醒来读一本书是多么美妙的一件事。它们太舒服了。就像你正陷进一颗美丽柔软的云朵里，它能让你阅读的任何内容都变得格外温馨舒适。我太喜欢了。我喜欢那样做。我喜欢在Helix床垫上阅读。
The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including award-winning Luxe Collection, the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Everybody is unique and everyone sleeps differently. That's why Helix has several different mattress models to choose from, each designed for specific sleep positions
Helix的产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制造的床垫。每个人都是独一无二的，每个人的睡眠方式也各不相同。这就是为什么Helix有几种不同的床垫型号可供选择，每一种都是为特定的睡眠姿势
and feel preferences. With so many options, you're probably thinking, which one is right for me? Just take the Helix sleep quiz to find your mattress in under two minutes. Once you've found your perfect match, Helix will ship it straight to your door free of charge. Helix is offering 25% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go
和触感偏好而设计的。面对这么多选择，你可能在想，哪一款才适合我？只需参加Helix睡眠测试，在不到两分钟的时间里就能找到你的专属床垫。一旦找到完美匹配的床垫，Helix就会免费将其直接运送到你家门口。Helix目前为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单85折优惠以及两个免费枕头。快去
to helixsleep.com slash smartlist and use code HelixPartners25. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. Helixsleep.com slash smartlist code HelixPartner25. With Helix, better sleep starts now smartless gets support from audible get closer to the best to you audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app you'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover there are many wellness categories for you to choose from on Audible, such as physical, mental, spiritual, social, motivational, occupational, and financial wellness. You'll find voices that'll motivate you to take action or sounds to soothe, to help
helixsleep.com斜杠smartlist并使用代码HelixPartners25。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。helixsleep.com斜杠smartlist代码HelixPartner25。选择Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。Smartless获得Audible的支持，让你更贴近最精彩的体验。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有的音频娱乐，你总能找到你喜爱的最佳内容或发现全新的内容。在Audible上有许多健康类别供你选择，例如身体、心理、精神、社交、动机、职业和财务健康。你会发现能激励你采取行动的声音，或是舒缓的声音，帮助你专注、减轻压力并睡得更好。作为Audible会员，你可以从整个目录中每月挑选一本想保留的有声书，包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。我刚开始听——我该怎么说呢？
you focus, reduce stress, and sleep better. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. I just started, how am I gonna say this? The subtle art of not giving a fuck. Eek. And obviously the beep is longer than the two letters that it's replacing in between, but it's or three
《不羁的艺术》（The subtle art of not giving a fuck）。额。显然，哔哔声比它中间替代的两个字母要长，或者说是三个字母
Because I the C as well. So it's it was you CK In case you didn't know anyway I'm listening to that on audible and it is absolutely fantastic Because not only do I like to read books when I'm not reading, I like to listen to books. Guys, I'm very popular. Anyway, as an Audible member, you can choose one title a month
因为我也把C算进去了。所以它是——U-C-K。以防你不知道，不管怎样，我正在Audible上听那本书，简直太棒了。因为我不但喜欢在不阅读的时候看书，我还喜欢听书。伙计们，我很受欢迎。不管怎样，作为Audible会员，你可以每月挑选一本有声书
to keep from the entire catalog. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 that's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless. Hello I am Alice Levine and I am one of the hosts of Wondries podcast British Scandal.
加入你的永久收藏，涵盖整个目录。新会员可以免费体验Audible 30天。访问audible.com斜杠smartless，或发送短信smartless到500-500。网址是audible.com斜杠smartless，或发送短信smartless到500-500，重复一遍，是audible.com斜杠smartless，或发送短信smartless到500-500，即可免费试用Audible 30天。请务必访问我们的网址，让他们知道是我们介绍你来的：audible.com斜杠smartless。大家好，我是爱丽丝·莱文（Alice Levine），我是Wondery播客《英国丑闻》（British Scandal）的主持人之一。
On our latest series The Race to Ruin, we tell the story of a British man who took part in the first ever round the world sailing race. Good on him I hear you say, but there is a problem, as there always is in this show. The man in question hadn't actually sailed before. Oh, and his boat wasn't sea-worthy. Oh, and also tiny little detail almost didn't mention it. He bet his family home on making it to the finish line. What Insued was one of the most complex cheating plots
在我们最新的系列节目《毁灭竞赛》（The Race to Ruin）中，我们讲述了一个英国男人的故事，他参加了史上第一次单人环球帆船赛。我猜你会说：好样的他！但有个问题，正如这个节目里一贯的那样。这位当事人其实以前从来没开过帆船。哦，而且他的船根本不适合航海。哦，还有个微不足道的细节我差点忘了提：他把家族的房子都押上了，赌自己能冲过终点线。随之而来的是
in British sporting history. To find out the full story, follow British Scandal wherever you listen to podcasts, or listen early and ad-free on Wondry Plus on Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. And now back to the show. All right, let's get to the show. You, I would imagine, yeah, do you love it as much as you seem?
英国体育史上最复杂的作弊阴谋之一。想要了解完整的故事，请在任何你听播客的地方搜索并订阅《英国丑闻》，或者在Apple Podcasts和Wondery App上的Wondery Plus抢先收听无广告版。现在回到节目中。好的，让我们回到节目中。你，我猜想，是的，你像表现出来的那么喜欢它吗？
I mean, it's like, seems like a fantastic fit for you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Can we go back to like, how did that happen? You're Kelly Clarkson, you have so many different phases to your life. You're Kelly Clarkson aspiring singer, you're Kelly Clarkson rock star. Not since Arnold Schwarzenegger.
我的意思是，这看起来简直完美契合你。对，对，对。我们可以回到——那是怎么发生的？你是凯莉·克莱斯顿，你的人生有那么多不同的阶段。你是怀揣歌手梦想的凯莉·克莱斯顿，你是摇滚巨星凯莉·克莱斯顿。自阿诺德·施瓦辛格以来还没见过这样的人。
And millions of albums. And then all of a sudden you're like, what? You're one day you wake up and you're like, man, you're looking out the window and you're like, I'm gonna day you wake up and you're like, man, you're looking out the window, you're like, I'm gonna have a talk show. No, no, that's, yeah, I said no the first two times. Like, so they, I was on The Voice and I love NBC. I have a really healthy relationship with them.
拥有数百万张专辑。然后突然之间你就像是——什么？你有一天醒来，就好像，天哪，你看着窗外，然后你就像是——我要有一天醒来，就像是，天哪，你看着窗外，然后你就像是——我要开个脱口秀。不，不，那是，对，前两次我都拒绝了。所以他们，我当时在《美国好声音》当导师，我非常热爱NBC。我和他们保持着非常健康的合作关系。
Well, they don't lie, so I like that. I've tried to surround myself with people that are just feed it to me. But I had a really good experience on that show with that crew, with those executives. And they came to the studio, I was doing something at the recording studio and they came and they were like,
嗯，他们不会撒谎，所以我很喜欢这点。我试着让自己周围的人都是直接跟我说实话的。但我在那个节目中与那个剧组、那些高管度过了一段非常美好的经历。他们来到录音室，当时我正在录音室里做点事情，他们走过来对我说，
we really feel like you would be really good at this. And I was like, I really am not a journalist or a comedian and there's like no reason for me to be doing that. Like I just don't think that's a good plan if I'm being frank. And then I said no, and then I said no again. And then all of a sudden it was just, you know, and it was actually my ex who, you know,
我们真的觉得你非常适合干这个。而我说，我真的既不是记者也不是喜剧演员，我没有任何理由去做那种事。说句实话，我觉得这不是个好主意。然后我拒绝了，接着我又拒绝了一次。然后突然之间，你知道的，其实是我的前夫，你知道的，
we were just laying in bed and he was like, I really feel like you should just, you'd be really good at it because you're really good with people, like you're really good at talking. I don't think it's gonna be like a job for you. Cause like, I think you just are really good at that. And, you know, why not just try it? And I was like, whatever.
我们当时正躺在床上，他说，我真的觉得你应该去试试，你会很适合的，因为你很擅长与人交往，你知道的，你很擅长聊天。我觉得这不会像是一份工作。因为我觉得你真的很擅长这个，而且，为什么不去试试呢？我就想，随便吧。
So I was like, okay, cool, I'll try it. And I will say even from the, and I say this, okay, cool, I'll try it. And I will say even from the, and I say this without trying to sound any other kind of way, but a lot of people will be like, oh, it's really hard. It's really not. It's like the easiest job I've ever had. Like I know that sounds like nobody wants to hear that. You wouldn't-
所以我就想，好吧，酷，我去试试。而且我必须得说，甚至从——我这么说，好吧，酷，我去试试。而且我必须得说，甚至从——我这么说并不是想装腔作势，但很多人会说，哦，这太难了。其实一点也不难。这简直是我干过最轻松的工作。我知道这听起来可能没人想听。你不会——
Because you're naturally charismatic and friendly and interested and curious. And it's like you've got people skills because you're naturally charismatic and friendly and interested and curious and it's like you just you've got people skills because you're not a dick You know, I mean like well, thank you But I I don't know I just it just is not like the hardest part my talk show is just that I was like Hey, I have this idea we can open with a song before and I could elevate You know other artists that I love or whatever whatever, and do covers, and whatever. And that's the hardest thing, it's like 180,
因为你天生具有个人魅力、友好、感兴趣而且充满好奇心。而且你拥有人际交往能力，因为你天生具有个人魅力、友好、感兴趣而且充满好奇心，而且你就是——你拥有人际交往能力，因为你不是个混蛋，你知道我的意思吗？——好吧，谢谢你，但——我不知道，我只是——这真不是最难的。我的脱口秀最难的部分只是——我当时说，嘿，我有个主意，我们可以在节目开始前唱一首歌，我可以借此推崇，你知道的，我喜爱的其他歌手或者诸如此类的东西，然后做翻唱，等等。而这才是最难的部分，简直是180度大转弯，
and it's always like trying to figure out, you know, clearing songs, like, that's the hardest part of the show, is just getting that, because there's no rehearsal time. It is literally like camp, like, you know, when you're a kid and they're like, get on stage, improv it, like, you know what I'm saying?
而且总是得去弄清楚，你知道的，获取歌曲版权，这才是节目最难的部分，就是搞定这个，因为根本没有排练时间。这简直就像夏令营，你知道的，当你还是个孩子的时候，他们会说，上台去，即兴发挥，你知道我在说什么吗？
It's like, it's like, it's, we literally don't rehearse it, We just do it, you know? It's the craziest thing ever. So that part is like the hardest part. The talking part is so easy. Well, except I know you've probably, well, maybe not cause you're like super successful. So, but like, you know, like, have you ever interviewed
就像是，我们真的不排练，直接就上，你知道的？这简直是最疯狂的事了。所以那部分可以说是最难的部分。聊天部分太简单了。好吧，除了我知道你可能已经——好吧，也许不会，因为你太成功了。所以，但是，你知道，就像，你有没有采访过
someone and you're just like, okay. So that's, that's- Yeah, like, but you don't gotta talk, you know? It's not, it's not yes or no time. I'm like, you know what? I'm here to help you sell your shit. Right, you're not doing me a favor by sitting on the couch. No, that can be hard sometimes.
某个人然后你心里只想说，好吧。所以，那是——对，就像，但你不用一直说话，你知道的？这不是只能回答“是”或“不是”的时间。我会想，你知道吗？我来这里是为了帮你的忙推销你的烂玩意儿。没错，你坐在沙发上并不是在帮我的忙。不，有时那确实很难。
I'm like, wow, do say more. But that can be tough. But for the most part, I'm pretty good with people. So it's really like the easiest, like I can't even believe we're in season five right now. It feels like not that long. That's so amazing. Yeah, I know.
我会想，哇，多说点吧。但这有时确实挺难的。但总的来说，我挺擅长跟人打交道的。所以这真的是最轻松的——我甚至不敢相信我们现在已经是第五季了。感觉没过去多久。太惊人了。是的，我懂。
It's so cool. Yeah, it's just a fun job. And honestly, the support of it, because I literally told the embassy, I was like, I don't. I'm not trying to slap a gift horse in the face, mouth, whatever you say, whatever the saying is. I was like, I'm just, I'm not happy here. I can't continue doing this.
太酷了。是的，这只是一份有趣的工作。老实说，关于它的支持，因为我真的对NBC说过，我没有——我不是想忘恩负义，或者不管你怎么说，随你怎么说。我当时说，我只是——我不快乐。我无法继续做下去了。
And I don't want to like, I know everybody's put a lot of money and time and we're winning and we're doing well. I was like, but I can't continue this. I got to get out of here. And so they were really cool about moving the show. That's really great. Which is huge.
我不想——我知道每个人都投入了大量的金钱和时间，我们在赢，我们做得很好。我当时说，但我无法继续下去了。我必须离开这里。所以他们在把节目搬迁这件事上表现得非常酷。这真的很棒。这可是个大动作。
To 30 Rock. Yeah. That's right. That's insane. Do you look at gift horse in the mouth? Do you know what it comes from? That's what it is. Do you know what it comes from?
搬到洛克菲勒中心30号（30 Rock）。是的。没错。这太疯狂了。你听说过“不能当面检查送来的马的牙齿”这个说法吗？你知道它出自哪里吗？就是那个意思。你知道它出自哪里吗？
I do. Do you? Yeah, if somebody, yeah, it goes back to somebody, you give somebody a horse and you look in the teeth and if the teeth are bad, then you say no, thank you. You can see how old the horse is and the overall health of a horse. And so if somebody gives you one and you go,
我知道。你真的知道？是的，如果有人，是的，这追溯到有人，你送给别人一马，然后你检查它的牙齿，如果牙齿不好，你就会说不用了，谢谢。你可以看出马的年龄以及马的整体健康状况。所以如果有人送你一匹马，然后你说，
yeah, I'll take the gift, but hang on, let me look inside and then you're gonna get this point. Yeah, yes, you're looking at the, it's rude. So yeah, so yeah. Look at that, the more you know, look at that. I don't know that Jason would know that, I love you, Jason. I'm sneaky smart. I know you are sneaky smart.
好吧，我接受这份礼物，但等一下，让我看看里面，然后你就会得到这个结论。对，没错，你在检查它的——这很不礼貌。所以，是的，就是这样。瞧瞧，知道得越多，懂的就越多。我不知道杰森会知道这个，我爱你，杰森。我其实是个隐藏的聪明人。我知道你是个隐藏的聪明人。
You're not sneaky smart, you're plain smart. Hey, so you, Kelly, you now at 30 Rock, which is must feel like, I mean, has it set it? Well, you know what's so funny is I've been going there so much for over 20 years that like, like for promotion stuff and just in and out of the building that I, it oddly felt very normal right off the bat. Like, yeah, I mean, you walk around like,
你不是隐藏的聪明人，你根本就是明面上的聪明。嘿，所以你，凯莉，你现在在洛克菲勒中心30号，这感觉一定像——我是说，适应了吗？好吧，你知道最搞笑的是什么吗，我过去20多年里为了各种宣传活动以及进出那栋大楼去了那里无数次，所以，
for some reason, my key like never works. They just don't want to let me in the building. And I always have to go to this one area and get another one. And when you go there, there's all these images that kind of change of all the things that have happened historically in that building. And it's so cool.
它出奇地从一开始就让我觉得非常正常。就像，是的，我的意思是，你在那里走来走去——不知为什么，我的门禁卡从来不管用。他们就是不想让我进大楼。我总是得去某个特定区域再拿一张。当你去到那里时，有各种不断变化的影像，展示着那栋大楼历史上发生过的一切。这太酷了。
Like, I mean, I get the gift of it and I'm very, you know, grateful for it. But it feels really normal. Like, we've been there the whole time. What floor are you on? Are you on six? I'm right across from, yeah, right across from Jimmy. You are? Okay.
我是说，我感受到了这份馈赠，并且对此非常感恩。但感觉真的很正常。就像我们一直都在那里一样。你在几楼？你在6楼吗？我就在对面，是的，就在吉米对面。真的吗？好吧。
Jimmy Fallon. Yeah. From Jimmy, oh sorry. Go ahead and run. For Tracy, Jimmy Fallon. Jimmy Fallon. I'm so jealous. It's such a dream of mine to live in New York, work at 30 Rock on something that is every day.
吉米·法伦。对。从吉米那——哦抱歉。你接着说。特雷西、吉米·法伦。吉米·法伦。我太嫉妒了。住在纽约，在洛克菲勒中心30号做一份每天播出的节目，这简直是我的梦想。
Like I swear to God, I've been, I've wanted that since I was, you know, a young kid, like going to New York for work and going to 30 Rock, I just think that building is incredible. The whole area around it, the even like the ice, all the closed off streets, there's something about it. The basement level of all the things happening
就像我发誓，我从——你知道的，还是个小孩子的时候就一直想要这个，去纽约工作，去洛克菲勒中心30号，我只是觉得那栋大楼不可思议。它周围的整个区域，甚至像溜冰场，所有封闭的街道，那里就是有一种特别的魅力。底层发生了那么多我以前从不知道的城市地下的故事
that I never knew the city underneath. I was like, what? Jason, are you crying right now? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm going to help you out. Sorry, go ahead, Kelly.
我当时就想：什么？杰森，你现在在哭吗？对不起。对不起。对不起。我要帮你解围。抱歉，凯莉，你继续。
I was going to say. I was going to say, I will say, it's how you're describing it. It is movie-like. Like, I walk home every day from work. And it's the coolest thing ever. You put your headphones in. I'm usually learning that, listening to what I'm supposed to be seeing the next day. But you walk home, you go out of the building.
我刚想说。我刚想说，正如你所描述的那样。这真的很像电影。就像，我每天步行下班回家。这简直是最酷的事情了。你戴上耳机。我通常是一边学台词，一边听我第二天该怎么演。但你步行回家，走出大楼。
This historical cool building, the city, everybody's got their own vibe going on, everybody's got their own lives, everybody's doing their own thing. You put different industries, not just the one in LA. Yeah. You put your headphones in, you walk home, and it's like a 35-minute walk home, and it's like a 35 minute walk home.
这座充满历史感的酷炫建筑，这座城市，每个人都有自己的生活节奏，每个人都有自己的生活，每个人都在做自己的事。这里汇聚了不同的行业，不仅仅是洛杉矶的那一个。是的。你戴上耳机，步行回家，那是一段大约35分钟的步行回家路程，大概是一段35分钟的步行回家路程。
And so it's nice, it's lovely, and you're walking through a park, and you're, it's really, it's like, I don't know the older we get, I sound like an old person, but the older you get, those moments really matter. Like those moments. Of course, it's experiential.
所以这很好，很美妙，而且你要穿过一个公园，这真的很——随着我们年龄越来越大，我听起来可能像个老年人，但随着年龄增长，那些时刻真的很重要。那些时刻。当然，这是一种切身体验。
Jay, we were talking on the phone this morning about it. So like how do you want your experience to be? Like you can have X, Y, and Z, but you have to go through the process of doing it and you have to do it on a day to day basis. So what do you want that to be? What do you want your life experience to be? And I know what you mean.
杰，我们今天早上还在电话里聊过这个。所以，你希望你的体验是怎样的？你可以拥有X、Y和Z，但你必须经历实现它的过程，而且你必须日复一日地去做。所以你希望那是什么样的？你希望你的人生体验是怎样的？我明白你的意思。
I mean, I lived in New York for over 20 years and I keep threatening that once my older kids graduate high school, I'm gonna move back. I think that's what I will do because of that very thing you talked about, whether it's walking to the park, walking to thing, whatever, I mean, that kind of stuff. It's very inspirational.
我是说，我在纽约住了20多年，我一直扬言等我的大孩子们高中毕业后，我要搬回去。我想我真的会那样做，就因为你刚才说的那种事，无论是散步去公园，还是散步去其他地方，我的意思是，那种感觉。这真的很受启发。
Yeah, it fills you up, right? Like it fills your soul, if you will. And it sounds like cheesy, but like, or very celebrity, but like I, at the risk of this I I have to be I think because I'm from the countryside. I have to be like like that park Saves me right there. Yeah, it saves me every day Like I I don't think I could live in the concrete jungle without that park Like I literally read a whole book on Frederick Law instead who created it.
是的，它能充实你的内心，对吧？就像它能滋养你的灵魂一样。听起来可能有点老套，或者非常像名利场人士的说法，但冒着被嘲笑的风险，我想说——因为我来自乡村。我必须——那个公园简直拯救了我的命。是的，它每天都在拯救我。我觉得如果没有那个公园，我根本无法在这个混凝土丛林里生活。我甚至读了整本关于设计它的弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德（Frederick Law Olmsted）的传记。
I'm very into like landscaping and very into like just making sure we have, we don't forget like what that feels like to go outside and see trees and flowers and. I did when I was doing the play last summer, I would walk sometimes I'd walk from your front door to the escalate. Yeah. You have exhausted.
我对园林绿化非常感兴趣，也非常注重确保我们不会忘记去户外看到树木和花卉是什么感觉。去年夏天我演话剧的时候，有时候我会从你正门步行到自动扶梯。你已经精疲力竭了。
I was exhausted. I was exhausted. Jason, can we just, can we make an announcement right now, Jake, can we, this is the NBC. Will and I are pregnant. Will and I are pregnant. Oh, wow. Congratulations.
我累坏了。我当时累坏了。杰森，我们现在能宣布个消息吗，杰，我们可以吗，这是NBC。我和威廉怀孕了。我和威廉怀孕了。哦，哇。恭喜。
Thanks, guys. The NBC, Jason Bateman is open to your offer of working for you at 30 Rock on a daily basis. You need like an epic man. So come to him. Sort of a... Call Alina Kishishina. Would y'all ever, would you, this is a real question. Uh-oh.
谢谢你们，伙计们。NBC的各位，杰森·贝特曼对你们在洛克菲勒中心30号全职工作的邀请持开放态度。你需要一个史诗级的男主角。所以联系他吧。有点像……给阿琳娜·基希娜（Alina Kishishina）打电话。你们会——这是一个真正的问题。噢哦。
Would you, because I'm not bullshitting you, I really do listen. I was, even with my sister and I, we were listening to like two in the morning last night, I think the Kevin Hart one and, and the Stone one, we were listening to a bunch of them. Anyway, and would you ever, because I noticed with the Kevin Hart one,
你们会——因为我真的没有瞎扯，我确实有在听。甚至昨晚凌晨两点，我和我姐姐还在听，我想听的是凯文·哈特那一期，还有史通那一期，我们听了好几期。不管怎样，你们会——因为我注意到凯文·哈特那一期，
you're in front of an audience and then y'all toured it as well. So would you ever do because I noticed with the Kevin Hart when you're in front of an audience, and then y'all toured it as well. So would you ever do it as like a, like a TV show? Like a TV talk show? Like a TV show? I've thought about it, but I think it would be more full time than I think the three of us would like.
你们是在观众面前录制的，然后你们还进行了巡演。所以你们会不会——因为我注意到凯文·哈特那一期你们是在观众面前录制的，然后你们还进行了巡演。所以你们会不会把它做成一个——就像一个电视节目？像一个电视脱口秀？像一个电视节目？我考虑过，但我认为这会比我们三个人想要的更全职。
Are willing to. Yeah, like right now it's just, you know, it's an hour a week, and it's, we can, we're flexible with it, we're mobile with it. But yeah, if it was a structured studio and stuff, it would mean stopping some of the other things we're enjoying doing in addition to this right now. But perfectly so.
我们愿意接受的程度。是的，现在它只是，你知道的，一周一个小时，我们可以灵活安排，随时随地都能做。但如果是固定演播室的节目，那就意味着必须放弃我们在做这个的同时还很享受的其他一些事情。不过完全可以理解。
And anybody who would wanna have us on their platform to do that would have to make an offer to Aline Kishin. Will has a number. And let's hear what it is, but sure. But I do think that you can make that whatever you want because I didn't know what a talk show was. Like I didn't really know, like, I didn't know this world. I'm an artist, I'm never even awake for daytime television.
任何想让我们在他们的平台上做这件事的人，都必须向阿琳娜·基希娜提出报价。威廉有个心理价位。让我们听听是多少，当然。但我确实认为你可以随心所欲地打造它，因为我以前根本不知道什么是脱口秀。我是说我真的不知道，我不了解这个世界。我是一名歌手，我甚至从来不在白天看电视节目。
Like I'm like, so like I'm, this is not really generally my world. So, you know, I think you've had so much success with it and obviously just in your careers separately. But I think that's the cool thing about it is that you wouldn't have to commit to more than what you wanted to commit to your that level to where maybe you do it in a different way. Like, you know, I don't know. I just think I think what you're doing, this is incredible. I just, it's just, I also understand like that is pretty cool to because because you do give up, something has to give.
所以我当时觉得，这通常不是我的世界。所以，你知道的，我觉得你们通过它取得了巨大的成功，而且显然仅仅在你们各自的职业生涯中也是如此。但我觉得最酷的地方在于，你不需要承诺超出你愿意投入的程度，也许你可以用不同的方式去做。比如，我不知道。我只是觉得你们正在做的这件事太不可思议了，只是，我也理解——因为你确实有所付出，必须有所舍弃。
Like even with my music career, I'm not able to do everything because I'm doing the talk show. But there's also a plus in that, for me, that's why it's so tempting. Like I love routine. I would love to have that stage across from Jimmy's and you have the pattern that you walk home every day
就像我的音乐生涯一样，我也无法面面俱到，因为我还要做脱口秀。但对我来说，这也是个加分项，这就是为什么它如此诱人。就像我喜欢规律。我很想拥有吉米对面那个舞台，而且你每天回家都会走同一条路
from through the park, like I love. I love a routine, I flourish in a routine. But also having that, as you know, because of what we do, sometimes you have like a million things happening at once. And again, not a complaint, like you know, you have the privilege of having a million things. But when you get to work on one thing all the time
穿过公园，我真的很喜欢。我喜欢有规律的生活，我在规律的生活中茁壮成长。但正如你们所知，由于我们所从事的工作，有时你会同时发生无数事情。再次说明，这并不是在抱怨，你知道的，你有幸能经历无数事情。但当你能够一直专注于做一件事时
and you can't, you're like, sorry, I can't, I'm just doing this thing, and there's something really satisfying about that. Having those moments, Sean, you did it for years on Will and Grace. Yeah, it was nice. You know, where you're like, I'm just doing this right now, and I don't have the time to be spread thin. For sure, right.
而你又做不到，你就会想，对不起，我做不到，我只能做这件事，而这其中有一种非常满足的感觉。拥有这些时刻，肖恩，你曾在《威尔和格蕾丝》里这样做过多年。是的，那感觉很好。你知道的，你会觉得，我现在只做这个，没有时间分身乏术。确实如此。
Because I'm just doing this. I know that you've answered this question probably a billion times. I've never heard the answer. That's why I'm gonna be the tool. I am a tourist as well. But no, why? Cause you all have such amazing careers
因为我只在做这件事。我知道你大概已经被问过这个问题无数次了。但我从未听过答案。这就是为什么我要当这个笨蛋。我也是个局外人。不过话说回来，为什么呢？因为你们都有如此精彩的职业生涯
separate from one another, such different careers as well. Obviously actors, but just different. And what made you all three do this? Like, whose idea was this? Will's originally, and then Sean and I kind of snored in on it and changed what Will's concept and premise was gonna be. And then it just became, well, let's just kind of hang out and chit chat during COVID because we can't see each other. We had no idea.
彼此独立，而且职业生涯也各不相同。显然都是演员，但又有所不同。是什么让你们三个人做这个的？这主意是谁出的？最初是威尔提出的，然后肖恩和我有点厚着脸皮加入了进来，并改变了威尔原本的构想和前提。后来就变成了，好吧，那就在新冠期间一起闲聊吧，因为我们见不到彼此。我们当时完全不知道。
I didn't know the answer to that. Sorry, you've probably answered it a billion times. No, it's not that. It's not particularly interesting. We literally were like, oh, let's just do it. And then we, and then the week, the world shut down on the Friday of March 13th of 2020. And we had a meeting on the Tuesday before like four days before. Yeah, yeah, Sean's Sean's real smart dude, Michael Grand Terry puts, puts some put some form to it and presented to us. Well, guys, just you know, this is what it could be and this is what it's not, you know?
我不知道这个答案。抱不歉，你可能已经被问过无数次了。不，不是这样的。其实也没什么特别有趣的。我们当时就想，哦，那我们就做吧。然后呢，在2020年3月13日星期五，世界就封锁了。我们在之前的那周星期二开过会，大概是四天前吧。对，对，肖恩真是个聪明人，迈克尔·格兰特·特里把它做成了一种形式并呈献给我们。好了，伙计们，你们知道吗，这可能是这样的，这不可能是那样的，懂吗？
Like, so don't think it's gonna be a big huge time suck and there's some work here, but he just basically put it in adult terms for us. And we paid for it, like we put it up on its feet on our own, I mean, it wasn't a lot, but we did that and that's how it's going to go. I think that that's why though, because it was so organic. I think, it wasn't a lot, but we did that. And that's how it's going to go. I think that that's why though, because it was so organic. I think, you know, a lot of horrible things happened
所以不要以为这会占用你大量的时间，这里面有些工作，但他基本上是用成人的方式向我们解释的。而且我们自己出资，我们靠自己的力量让它运转起来，我的意思是，虽然钱不多，但我们确实这么做了，事情就这样发展下去了。我想这就是原因所在，因为它非常自然。我想，钱虽然不多，但我们确实这么做了。事情就这样发展下去了。我想这就是原因所在，因为它非常自然。我想，你知道的，很多可怕的事情发生了
because of COVID, but a lot of really incredible things happened out of COVID. And it was just an excuse to see each other, you know? Yeah. Well, it became like this really great, you know, we, a lot of feedback we got, especially at that time from people was like, hey, it was great to be able to listen during COVID.
是因为新冠，但新冠也带来了一些非常了不起的事情。这只是一个见彼此的借口，对吧？是的。嗯，它变成了这样一个非常棒的节目，你知道的，我们收到了很多反馈，特别是在那个时候，人们说，嘿，能在新冠期间听到这个节目真的很棒。
And truthfully, it was selfishly, it was it was great to be able to listen during COVID. And truthfully, it was selfishly, it was great for us to be able to do it directly. Oh, it was selfishly, it was good for me to work through that as well. I worked my whole TV show the whole time. Right, and being able to like- In the mountains and like snow. And being able to call people in
老实说，自私地说，能在新冠期间听到这个节目真的很棒。老实说，自私地说，能让我们直接做到这一点，对我们来说太棒了。哦，自私地说，这对我克服那个困难也有好处。我整个过程都在做我的电视节目。对的，而且能够——在山里，还有雪中。而且能够打电话给
that you're really interested to talk to kind of unapologetically, you're not like tapping them in the shoulder like, excuse me, Mrs. Such and Such, I'd love to ask you a question. Well, no, we have a format for that with this, and it's such a luxury to be able to talk to these heroes that we have. I'm sure you feel the same way on your show.
那些你真的很想交谈的人，毫无歉意地，你不是那种拍拍别人的肩膀说，不好意思，某某太太，我想问你一个问题。哦，不，我们为此有一个专门的形式，能够同我们心目中的这些英雄交谈简直是一种奢侈。我相信你在你的节目中也有同感。
Yeah, I do. You just say to your gang, your producers, hey, would you reach out to Such and Such, see if they'd be interested in coming on the show? She's in a gang? Yeah. No, that just happened to me with Cher. I was like, and Alanis was on this season,
是的，我也有。你只要对你的团队、你的制作人说，嘿，你们能联系一下某某，看看他们有没有兴趣上节目？她有个团队？对。不，我刚在雪儿身上遇到这种事。我当时想，而且阿兰妮斯这季也来了，
like a lot of people that I adore, they're always gonna be more, the musical ones that come on just cause I, and have a little bit more depth with them as far as their career and catalog and stuff. But yeah, I feel the same way. It's the coolest thing to like be able to just sit and chat like with your people that you look up to.
就像许多我崇拜的人一样，总是会有更多人，特别是那些来参加节目的音乐人，因为我对他们的职业生涯、作品集等等有更深的了解。不过是的，我有同感。能够就这样坐着和你仰慕的人聊天，是最酷的事情。
Well, you're killing it. You really are. You've killed it. And everything you've done, you're such a sort of real. Say lovely. Say lovely. Lovely person. I could hear you talk all day long.
嗯，你太棒了。真的。你太厉害了。在你的所有成就中，你就是那种非常真实的人。说得真好。说得真好。可爱的人。我可以听你讲一整天。
I could hear you sing all day long. I agree. I love it. You're nice. I don't leave voicemails because of my talking voice. I just want to belt out all your songs to you because I just love, I love belting out your songs the way it's just so good. We have taken up way too much of your time. God, you're busy.
我可以听你唱一整天。我同意。我太喜欢了。你太好了。因为我的说话声音，我都不留语音留言。我只想对你大声唱出你的所有歌曲，因为我就是喜欢，我喜欢大声唱出你的歌曲，那种感觉太棒了。我们占用了你太多时间了。天哪，你太忙了。
Get back to your incredibly successful talk show. We wish you nothing but the best. Thank you for being here and blessing us with you. And thank you for your talent and everything you've done and just continued success. And all your lovely, yeah. Yeah, you're awesome. No, thank you guys for having me.
回去做你那极其成功的脱口秀吧。我们祝你一切都好。谢谢你来到这里，并把你的祝福带给我们。谢谢你的才华，谢谢你所做的一切以及你将持续取得的成功。还有你所有可爱的地方，对。是的，你太棒了。不，谢谢你们邀请我。
I know I've listened to the show. So I like to be in the same category as a lot of the people that you interview is very cool. So thank you very much for having me. Oh, yeah. And you make, like honestly, just like cutting through the bullshit and just being yourself, it's so refreshing to listen to and it's fun and it's I don't you know how y'all were saying people look at me I I look at y'all the same way, so I think it's very refreshing for people
我知道我听过这个节目。所以能和你们采访的许多人归为同一类，我觉得非常酷。所以非常感谢你们邀请我。哦，是的。而且你，老实说，就是那种直截了当、做自己的态度，听起来太清爽了，而且很有趣，我不知道，你知道你们怎么说人们怎么看我，我也以同样的方式看待你们，所以我认为这对人们来说非常耳目一新
Thanks for people to see this version of Shawn for sure Yeah, Kelly, thank you so much success. Congratulations and wish you nothing but the best. Yes. Now y'all have a good 2024, y'all. You too. You too, see you later. Bye, Kelly.
感谢人们看到肖恩的这一面，真的。是的，凯莉，非常感谢你。祝你成功。恭喜你，祝你一切都好。是的。好了，祝你们大家2024年过得愉快。你们也是。你们也是，回头见。再见，凯莉。
What a terrible guest, Will. You know, somebody that just doesn't know how to, you know, be friendly or respond to questions. I know, she's so, I love this. Sean, you started in the right way, which is you put it in such a great way, which is like, yeah, she feels very much like. Like hours.
多糟糕的嘉宾啊，威尔。你知道的，就是那种不知道怎么，你知道的，表现得友好或者回答问题的人。我知道，她太，我太喜欢这个了。肖恩，你一开始的方式就很好，你把它表达得太棒了，就像是，是的，她感觉非常像。就像我们自己人一样。
Like hours. Yeah. And she is the American Idol. Yeah, she's American. She represents all sides of America. I think. I honestly felt like I could fire up a friendship with her tomorrow that would last 40 years.
就像我们自己人一样。是的。她就是美国偶像。是的，她是美国人。我认为她代表了美国的所有方面。老实说，我觉得明天我就能和她建立一段能持续40年的友谊。
Well, when you're doing your talk show across the hall from her, Jason. Yeah, do that. Or maybe combined with her. What? Kelly and Jason. From Jason DeKelley. From Jason DeKelley. That was the name of the movie.
好吧，当你跟她的脱口秀隔着走廊时，杰森。是的，那就这么做。或者也许和她合并。什么？凯莉和杰森。从杰森·德·凯莉。从杰森·德·凯莉。那是电影的名字。
That's right, from Justin DeKelley. Justin DeKelley, that was the name of the movie. Yeah, that's not a people comedy, Justin, all the time. From Jason Dekelly But isn't amazing we know all of her songs like it's so rare like everybody knows all her I know what's that song that goes? Bye bye black sheep black sheep, black bird? Yeah. Yeah. Fuck, man. Jason, why'd you go out of here?
没错，从贾斯汀·德·凯莉。贾斯汀·德·凯莉，那是电影的名字。是的，那不是大众喜剧，贾斯汀，一直都是。从杰森·德·凯莉。不过，我们知道她所有的歌，这难道不神奇吗？太难得了，每个人都知道她所有的我懂，那首歌怎么唱的？再见，再见，黑羊，黑羊，黑鸟？是的。是的。靠，老杰森，你为什么走开？
That was so fucking sweaty. I was like, what? Fucking lather up. No, you're thinking about that in sync song. Yeah, how's it go? Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. Smart.
那真是太他妈让人冒汗了。我当时想，什么？妈的，满头大汗。不，你在想那首超级男孩的歌。对，它是怎么唱的？拜，拜，拜。拜，拜，拜，拜，拜。聪明。
Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbicot, and Michael Grant Terry. SmartLess If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus
最后。聪明。最后。聪明。最后。SmartList 由 Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbicot 和 Michael Grant Terry 100% 手工精心打造。SmartLess 如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入 Wondry Plus 在 Wondry 应用或 Apple Podcasts 上提前收听无广告版
in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondery.com slash survey. Today, hip-hop dominates pop culture. But it wasn't always like that. And to tell the story of how that changed, I want to take you back to a very special year in rap. 88, it was too much good music. The world was on fire. Yeah. I'm Will Smith. This is Class of 88, my new podcast about the moments, albums and artists that inspired
在 Wondry 应用或 Apple Podcasts 上收听。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。在您离开之前，请在 Wondry.com/survey 填写简短问卷，让我们了解您。今天，嘻哈音乐主导着流行文化。但情况并非一直如此。为了讲述这一改变的故事，我想带大家回到说唱中非常特别的一年。88年，有太多优秀的音乐。世界在燃烧。我是威尔·史密斯。这是《88届》，我的新播客，讲述那些激发了
a sonic revolution and secured 1988 as one of hip hop's most important years. We'll talk to the people who were there. And most of all, we'll bring you some amazing stories. You know what my biggest memory from that tour is? It was your birthday. Yes, and you brought me to Shoday. Life-sized artwork cut out. This is Class of 88, the story of a year that changed hip hop.
声音革命并确立1988年为嘻哈音乐最重要年份之一的时刻、专辑和艺术家。我们将与亲历者交谈。最重要的是，我们将带给你一些精彩的故事。你知道我那次巡演最大的记忆是什么吗？是你的生日。是的，你带我去了Shoday。真人大小的艺术剪纸。这是《88届》，一个改变了嘻哈音乐的年份的故事。
Follow Class of 88 on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Wondry 应用或你获取播客的任何地方关注《88届》。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。